Must be from New York.
Yeah.
Well you could definitely tell that
four,
three,
two.
And we're live.
John Joseph,
how are you?
This is like,
I'm excited and I'm excited to for.
I think it could set a nice precedent
because there's so much fucking toxic
energy between vegans and non vegans.
Even if we're just joking around,
people get so fucking angry and it's not
necessary.
Absolutely.
I mean,
where's the humor?
Where's the comedy?
Yeah.
I mean,
the other thing is I don't sit around
like I'm not defined by what the fuck I
eat.
Like,
like this dude said,
how come you don't call yourself a
Vegan?
I'm like,
because I do a lot more shit than just
eat plant based food is part of what I
do.
But don't you call yourself a Vegan?
Me.
You are a Vegan,
right?
Uh,
I practiced that a lifestyle for sure.
But I don't call myself a Vegan.
Um,
that's interesting.
I would say people say,
uh,
you know,
how do you,
I don't like to put any type of material
laid label on myself and if somebody
says to me and push the issue,
I'm like,
I'm more of a higher Krishna Bhakti Yoga
person than I am a Vegan,
you know,
even though I don't wear animal
products,
I don't use animal products.
I eat a plant based diet,
100 percent,
um,
but uh,
to call myself,
that just puts me in some,
you know,
some shelf,
oh,
it's just another Vegan or whatever the
fuck,
you know,
it seems to me as though people are
always searching for an identity and if
they have an identity that I'm a,
I'm a carnivore,
I'm on the carnivore diet,
which has all the latest trends and then
people get really hopped up on that and
that's all they want to do is talk
carnivore diet to the difference between
what's happening right now with this
carnivore diet.
And vegans seems very similar to me in
that they're very into the identity of
their food,
not their food choices,
but certainly into the fact that this is
how they identify.
They talk about it all the time and I
just think this photo,
there's pitfalls in that.
There's traps that people fall into
where they lock their identity into a
group.
Absolutely.
And this is what happens with vegans,
it happens to hunters.
It happens with Republicans,
happens with Democrats.
It just becomes a group thing.
And then you automatically oppose
people,
the other group,
and you have like,
you have a conflict with them,
you have hate with them.
Do we need more walls?
You don't need more adults.
And I'll tell you what really got it for
me.
And I started doing this in [inaudible]
81 before anybody.
I came out of incarceration.
I came out of abusive foster homes.
My father was a professional fighter,
tried to murder my mom,
peter continuously.
I didn't even find out I,
you know,
that I was conceived that of a rape from
him on my mom.
So getting locked up,
hitting the streets and then meeting the
bad brains in 1980 and seeing them and
who they were surrounded by.
It was a lot of uh,
you know,
people who were into very metaphysical
stuff.
So I got into the yoga and I know you've
been doing yoga now too.
So one of the first tenants of the yoga
practice,
which slams all it ish.
All this label shit is a Hump Brahmasmi
that I'm actually,
my identity is a spirit soul.
It beyond anything in the material
world,
any label you want to put on yourself.
So that's really where I come from with
the whole thing.
And I think the toxicity level that is
existing now just because of what people
fucking,
you know,
choose to eat.
I mean I have my issues with a certain
things that are being done because of,
because of the condition of the planet
and we're not being good custodians of
this planet that were in charge for kids
and future generations.
What's being done now.
There's industries that are destroying
the planet.
Like,
you know,
some of it is irreparable damage being
done,
but I really try to keep it
metaphysical,
uh,
with everything I do and who I help.
I mean,
I'm working on a documentary right now
at here,
30 year life with hardcore fucking ex
cons.
I just did 20,
25 years,
30 years.
If I go in there trying to preach them
some Vegan shit to them,
um,
I'm coming out.
I'm like a fucking like,
Yo,
dude,
this is where I've been.
I,
I've been where you are.
People helped me and I'm,
I'm here to help you.
I,
we didn't start out.
You know,
we don't even say,
you know,
we said,
we're going to put you on a plant based
Diet.
What are you going to do?
Tell them don't wear leather.
Fucking shoes.
Don't do this.
Don't,
do you know the whole thing.
Even when Jay z and beyonce is never
enough.
Okay.
They went and did you know they said
Vegan,
right?
Okay.
We were practicing a Vegan Diet.
We're doing a 30 day Vegan.
So what are the vegans do?
Attack them all,
but he fucking leather and it's,
you have to be able to find the spark.
So if you see some goodness in someone,
you have to be able to fan that spark,
not throw water on it.
And that's the problem that's being done
is people are so judgmental because
they've built this walls,
the walls between them that um,
it's just for finding.
And I was telling the guys,
I trained them this morning,
we're doing this 30 to life.
We kipp in Anniston and we're at the
amity foundation where these guys got
paroled.
And I said,
look,
there's two types of mentality in the
world.
There's the Bema mentality that's
looking for the sweet and the good in
people.
And then there's the flies and they
looking for the shit.
I said,
when you see shit on a sidewalk and a
dog takes a shit or in New York,
uh,
you know,
a human takes a shared within a matter
of fucking 20 seconds.
There's flies on that motherfucker.
So I try to roll with the PMA,
which I learned from bad brains,
positive mental attitude,
which Napoleon Hill,
her copped it from Napoleon Hill,
think and grow rich and all those books
on self out.
And it was like he told me no matter
what circumstances you may be in.
And I was in the navy at the time in
Norfork fucking smuggling,
fucking up catching cases came out and
took,
took navy over,
going back to jail.
And I was fucking up.
I didn't know what to do.
Fuck out of my mind hanging out with
Henry rollins and Ian Mci and all those
guys in the DC hardcore scene in New
York punk scene and you know,
hanging with John Belushi on fear that
night.
We were the ones that wreck the set of
Saturday night live and just,
you know,
the just doing crazy shit.
And he was just told me,
you know,
whatever you may be going through in
life,
if you keep a positive mental attitude,
you could get through anything.
So how am I going to criticize people
just because,
uh,
you,
you eat meat or do whatever.
It's like,
you know,
and some of these people are hardcore
Christians and it's like you're supposed
to say,
hey,
what,
you know,
hate the sin,
not the sinner or whatever the fuck that
whole philosophy deals with.
I mean,
my point is I'm trying to knock down the
walls between people and unify people,
so
I think what you do good is you,
you're a very positive role model in
terms of hard work,
in terms of your,
your,
your mental fortitude and how you
approach things and I think people need
that and I think one of the things
that's going on right now with social
media and one of the reasons why people
will attack Jay z four and leather
shoes,
even though they're,
they're looking to stand out,
they're looking to be virtuous.
They're looking to be the person that's
more virtuous than the person.
We're pointing a finger at,
man,
fuck them.
And there's always a lot of fuck people
who aren't this or fuck people who
aren't that.
She'd never say fuck people because
people are.
They're just like you.
They're human beings and everybody's on
a different path.
Tell me why you believe the way you
believe.
Tell me why you think the way you think,
and I'll tell you why.
I think the way I think and I bet we'll
find common ground and that's what human
beings need to do more with each other.
The problem with social media is it
gives us this them this unusual platform
to get people to pay attention to their
ideas when maybe their ideas aren't even
that good or maybe their ideas are very
obvious.
You know,
like you're gonna appointed someone,
hey man,
you know you shouldn't say this word.
Hey man,
you shouldn't do this thing because that
we've decided that that's a bad thing.
We've decided that that's culturally
unacceptable anymore and now everyone's
gonna attack for that very reason.
Instead of describing how they feel,
what makes them feel when they say
something,
what makes them feel when they do
things,
where what's going on in their head so
we can all relate on common ground.
People just want to attack and it's a
big problem with social media is way too
young.
It's a new thing and people are using it
and he's really fucked up ways.
They don't exactly know what they're
doing while they're doing it.
They're not even aware of the effect of
their printed word.
What's going to have.
That's why you have so many trolls and
so many mean people and so many people
just trying to get a rise out of
someone.
They're not even aware of the process
they're setting in motion.
They just know they could push a button
and watch something happened that just
going,
Ooh,
I mean this is,
this is a lot of what's going on today.
I mean,
and some of this stuff is,
is destroying people's lives.
What they fucking do.
And they don't.
They don't realize that,
um,
you know,
it,
it's a shame because,
uh,
like when I was growing up,
we didn't have social media,
there was no motherfucking Internet,
there was no,
none of you know,
I remember I had the first pager.
It was fucking gigantic.
So like,
we didn't even have no internet.
Everything was word of mouth.
And if you wanted to catch shows,
if you wanted to do this,
if you had a beef with somebody,
you didn't go on fucking social media
and talk a bunch of bullshit,
you fucking walked up to the person and
you said,
hey,
here I am and what the fuck,
let's let's deal with this.
Let's talk about it,
talk it out.
But now you got people buying followers
and do another.
It's just that it's,
you know,
it's just the most toxic environment in
a lot of ways.
And it's a shame because it could be
used.
And that's why I never post negative
shit.
I tried to use the platform,
you know,
make light of Shit and not have a stick
up your ass.
There's too many people that do even the
plant based Vegan thing and everything
so fucking serious.
I'm like,
you might reach more people if you
lightened up,
you know,
like stripes.
Lighten up Francis.
Yeah.
I think if you say you eat meat,
well you did write a book called me this
proposal.
I'll tell you how that came about.
And actually I got attacked.
I'm going to tell you something else you
want to talk about destroying people.
I got attacked more by the Vegan
feminists for that book.
Fucking tried to destroy me,
everybody because I wrote push now first
of all.
And then she,
she went on a blog and called me a
misogynistic.
I said,
yeah,
like massages the but you know,
call me and misogynistic scumbag and
then fucking piece of shit and all this.
So I just had,
I just wrote a,
Hey,
any of you ladies that bought this book
for the,
for the fellows and it helped them
please fucking Holler at this fucking
woman and tell some.
They shut her fucking blog down.
And then she called me a maniac and I
said,
let's call Germanium.
Send people on her the way she sent,
but dig this.
And then I said,
we have,
we have a saying on the streets in New
York back in the day.
Don't start nothing.
There won't be none.
I say,
you know,
but the thing was,
I'm going to tell you how that book
title came about because it was a woman
actually Karen Rinaldi from a Harper
Collins wave.
And what happened was,
uh,
I was training at crunch.
Aaron Dragos Winooski is my trainer and
he's gotten me through all my fucking
Iron Mans,
everything.
I was a fucking broken up person,
injuries all this shit.
So I'm working.
I was working at crunch and training
with him.
And then another person,
a friend of mine,
all the five points guys used to be
there.
You would see them all.
They had a ring on the second floor.
So this guy was doing pad work and I'm
telling them,
hey,
you know,
listen man,
you got a fight coming up,
man,
get on the chlorophyll,
get onto wheat grass,
get on,
you know,
eat as much recovery foods as you can
that's going to fight inflammation.
So some fucking Momma Luke with fucking
19 eighties tiger striped pants.
Fuck it.
Fuck you.
You know,
you're like,
he,
he just took everything out of context.
And then he's like,
you're fucking people that don't want me
to fucking pussies,
you know,
my uh,
yeah,
you got like 50 pounds on me,
but if you want to put some head gear
and get in the ring,
I'll oblige you.
He's like,
what?
I said I don't eat meat bro.
And then the funny shit with the whole
book title was it was going to be called
to grow green road to health,
fitness and longevity and business
partner Todd Erland goes,
motherfucker,
who are you?
Dr Oz.
Nobody wants to hear that book.
Familiar John Blood Clot Joseph singer
from the Cro mags they want.
And then I post it,
they will.
And then I said,
yeah.
I said,
yeah,
this motherfucker was like,
you know,
saying fucking people that don't eat me
to push these on my motherfucker.
That dude ain't seen his dick in fucking
10 years.
He was overweight and all this shit.
I said that motherfuckers to pussy.
And he's like,
Yo,
you know what?
Throw it back in her face.
And I was like,
I don't know man.
That's,
you know,
that's a pretty bold statement.
He said,
do it.
Do it.
So we released so right away to fuck and
emails and the texts that way.
Yo,
that's how it started.
And then we uh,
our agent Dan,
we got hooked up with this guy,
Dan from ICM.
He's like,
met my business partner in the Hamptons.
She's like,
Yo,
that book is fucking dope man.
I think we could get a deal within a
week.
He had four offers.
So you wrote it first?
Yeah,
I wrote it first and we put it out.
So it was the thought process behind
writing it.
You just had a lot of shit in your head.
Just wanted to get out.
Yeah.
Well I studied writing under Robert
Mckee,
so I wrote my memoir first.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Story.
I fucking that guys like my guru for
writing.
I,
I took,
I took the story seminar twice.
He's fucking amazing.
I mean Brian Cox,
his portrayal of him and fucking in a
adaptation fucking brilliant spot on.
So.
And you know,
I,
I actually became friends with Robert
with Mr Mckee.
I would.
He smoked like crazy.
Realized.
Yeah.
He smoked cigarettes.
I A fucking CIM lot of writers do,
man.
Yeah,
but not during the class.
So when he had the breaks he would
fucking do like two,
three cigarettes.
I said,
you know,
my friend has an organic green tea
extract company and the Polyphenols in
that is going to counteract all your
fucking smoking shit that you're doing.
So I gave him five bottles and then
every time he would call,
he would have his people call Yo,
you know that guy fucking Miguel and get
them to bring me some more of that green
tea shit.
Did he quit smoking?
I don't know.
I haven't seen him in.
The problem is it gives them a charge.
Some,
uh,
you know,
a nootropic charge fires up your brain.
Yeah.
It's a smoke a cigarette man.
I smoked like crazy.
I used to Kools in lock up and shit,
like,
you know,
because that's what they gave you in
Spofford.
And uh,
and when I went upstate it was,
cools quit.
I quit because I started boxing in lock
up and they would have us run this
fucking hill called suicide hill and I
will be fucking puking.
And I was like,
I gotta quit fucking smoking.
So I quit smoking,
they used to do smoker fights in lockup.
So if you had a beef with somebody you
went into this rec room was explained
smokers to people,
they don't know what that means.
Smoker,
fights means you just have a beef with
somebody and you could just throw on the
gloves and,
and go at it.
And as long as it's like reasonably
within 20 pounds of weight difference,
like,
you know,
although in lockup I saw people much
bigger people fighting much smaller
people in,
some of them guys.
I mean I was,
I was not good.
I got,
I would fight the black dudes and they
would just beat the shit out of me,
but I would just keep coming back.
You know,
I'm Irish,
I don't quit man.
I was [inaudible] then,
you know,
I learned more of the sweet science and
went into the navy and.
And so you quit smoking just for boxing.
I quit smoking A.
Yeah,
for that,
for that reason.
But when I was locked up,
I didn't quit almost to the end because
towards the end of your sentence,
they allow you to go home because they
want to reintegrate you back with your
family or whatever.
And I never grew up with my mom so they
would send us home.
So we would take the continent
cigarettes and opening up very
carefully,
open up the cellophane,
carefully slide the cellophane down and
put joints inside the cigarette pack,
slide it back up,
glue it closed the cart and cigarettes.
And that's how we would get the feedback
from the visits because I wasn't smoking
weed coming back out of.
Nobody's asked.
That was,
I'm like,
no,
thank you.
So,
uh,
that,
you know,
so that was the process and um,
so that's why,
that's why I quit.
But that's the book came,
uh,
I had a lot of shit,
a lot of demons inside of me from what
happened to me,
me and my two brothers was,
you know,
pretty severely abused and all kinds of
ways in his foster home,
physically,
mentally,
sexually abused by the older kids in the
home.
It was fucked up and I never told
anybody,
but that was always something,
no matter how much I lived as a monk for
two years or Hari Krishna Monk,
nothing,
a cure,
that fucking anger that was inside of me
that I had toward these people for what
they did to me.
And the secret of like,
Yo,
it's fucked up to say like,
just do from the streets.
You had knife fights with Puerto Rican.
I,
I got shot with a 22 and forest parks on
angel dust.
I got stabbed and then to try to say,
Yo,
this motherfucker molesting me is wwe.
It took a lot out of me too.
And nobody knew it because I never
talked about it.
And I took my keys class and that was
the turning point because I went up to
him and I was writing a script at the
time based on what happened to me in the
foster home.
The kids in the screenplay.
We based,
uh,
what,
what happened to me,
uh,
in,
in my younger,
a period of my life.
And I never told anybody what happened.
I would just avoid that,
but then when I wrote,
I started writing the book and I was
taking his class and between,
uh,
you know,
parts of his thing,
when you went on a break,
you could walk up to Robert Mckee and
say,
ask him questions.
So I said,
Mr Mckee as far as a protagonist who was
abused as a kid and he stopped me right
there and he said,
listen,
stop.
Right Day said McGowan,
everybody uses it.
It's a cliche,
you know,
abusive children,
uh,
to develop empathy for characters we
could otherwise not give a fuck about.
It's not what happens to somebody,
it's what they do as a result of it.
And that's the fucking light came on.
And I mean,
for years I would sit there and it took
me seven years to write the evolution of
a cro magnon and I would get to that
part of the story and I will lose my
shit and break down crying like fucking
uncontrollably because of what happened
to me and my brothers.
So I just skipped over that part and I
would never address it.
But then,
you know,
he gave me the strength and a lot of
ways to be able to say,
hey man,
you got to tee.
He wrote in my book,
so I have his book and he wrote to me,
he goes,
John always write the truth and that's
when I knew that that needed to come out
in the book to cleanse myself.
I've been two years on crack,
a 88,
88 to 90 crack pills,
you know,
doing whatever getting shot at with
fucking ear fifteens robin deals.
I had a tos or not.
It was chaos at the time,
kill on site.
I was,
I was a fucking maniac because I just
didn't care.
I actually kind of wish subconsciously
that somebody would put a fucking bullet
at me.
We're doing crack.
A lot of people get molested.
They almost act out to the point where
they want someone else to do it for them
because they don't want to.
Yeah,
I was definitely in a lot of ways that's
what I was doing.
But when I took a his,
when that seminar helped me so much
because it's really like,
he's really like a fucking a guru and a
teacher man.
The man is amazing.
If you ever get a chance to take the
Robert Mckee story seminar,
two,
three day seminar.
I took it twice,
then he does workshops.
But the story seminar,
I just walked out of there after the
third day is 10 hours a day and you're
just like,
you fucking,
you like speeches.
Like what the fuck did I just
experience?
It's incredible.
And,
and that gave me the power to go and
tell my story the right way and the
amount of emails of people that I
received that will like,
Yo,
that shit was done to me.
Thank you for having the courage to tell
the story.
And um,
you know,
I just kept writing after that.
So even the meat is for pussies.
A book was,
you know,
if you read it,
it's tongue and cheek.
I'm not calling.
There's a lot of dudes that eat meat
that could kick the shit out of me.
I'm not saying what I'm saying is if you
continue to lead a sanitary lifestyle
and you eat this fucked up food that's
out there that they're putting out
there,
that they are knowingly putting out
there to fucking poison you because
they're tied in with the pharmaceutical
companies.
It's a racket.
It's it,
it's not a conspiracy has been proven
that this is what they're doing.
You will become a pussy dependent on the
pharmaceutical companies to keep you
alive.
If you,
if that's what you want,
then this book is not for you.
Put it back.
So you
got into Hari Krishnas and you got into
this whole consciousness trip from the
bad brains,
which is crazy.
Like think about that.
Like people would assume like,
you think the hardcore scene you think
at a drugs and violence and tattoos and
namaste and you are getting into that.
So tell me about that.
How'd you get into Hari Krishnas?
I'm going to tell you.
So,
um,
initially my first and my first
interaction with Rastafarian's,
it was 1980.
So I went to my ship was going to
Jamaica.
So when you go to any,
when you go take this,
let's say you go to any port and they
take you down on the mess deck and they
show everyone,
you go here,
you go there,
they're like,
they show you these films.
So when we were getting ready to go to
Jamaica,
they're like,
if you're going to use,
and it's these like military films from
like the sixties,
if you're gonna use,
uh,
you know,
have sex with a prostitute and make sure
you use a prophylactic.
And then the next photo was a fucking
Rastafari in with smoke coming out of
every fucking or FIS.
And they're like,
and under no circumstances should you
talk to these people,
they're just going to try to sell you
drugs.
So who the fuck do you think was the
first people I went when I got off the
ship because I didn't hang out with like
any of the dudes on my ship.
I got the fuck away from.
I was the only punk rocker.
I was wearing sex pistols,
destroy fucking tee shirts.
They're looking at me like I was already
into punk rock since the seventies.
So I get off the ship and I meet this
like 20 something year old fucking
dread,
dread dude.
And he's like,
yeah,
mom,
what you need?
I said,
listen,
I,
you know,
I'm fucking smuggling some weed back.
I,
I wanna I want to get,
take [inaudible] this other sale at told
me,
Yo,
you go in there and you get them to take
you to the carving shops and they carve
out the fucking statue and they packed
the lamb's bread in there and then seal
up the statue.
And then I had a hookup with uh,
the officer,
the guy who did the watch and counted.
So say every fifth person you got
searched.
So I was always avoided that because I
will hit the dude off with some weed or
whatever the fuck it was.
So when I went to Jamaica,
I asked this kid as soon as I got off
the boat,
like there was no hotels in Montego Bay,
nothing.
It was just,
you took the ship,
the ship anchored out in the bay and you
took a boat in and landed at the dock.
And it was just like some fucking
ancient,
like crazy shit like that you would see
back in $1,800 for sale report and then
there's two was eating his carton a
fucking shit.
I might kill 'em.
I'm like French fries and Burgers at the
time.
And I'm like,
Yo,
what the fuck are you eating?
What is that shit?
He's like,
yeah,
I'm on this color,
Lou and Aki.
And he's like Manya,
he shall live to 150 to Ross.
I was like,
really?
I said,
let me check that shit out.
Took one fork full.
And I just was like,
that's fucking disgusting.
Shit.
Tastes like dirt dude.
What was it?
It was Carla Lou Lou Lou is a green.
It's like one of the most nutritious,
Collard Green.
Yeah,
it's like Collard Green.
It's like they have a day of Greens down
there that don't really grow anywhere
else.
So I think it's like a combination of
Kale and Collard Greens.
And then Aki is like this fruit and it
looks like it's yellow.
It looks like an egg almost.
But if you eat Aki when it's not ripe,
you'll die.
You get poisoned.
It's this type of thing.
Like when the fruit opens up the.
It's like a red fruit.
If you eat it when it's not open,
you will die.
Really?
Yeah.
Aki Aki will poison you.
And then.
And then he was eating seaweed and beans
and anyway,
so I went up into the hills.
He took me.
Now I don't know if you like reggae,
but I do.
I fucking love Gregory.
So do you know where Peter Tosh?
I'm wanted shredder alive.
Do you know where that came from?
No.
Okay.
I'm going to tell you.
So back in,
I think it was 78,
this cop,
they hate the roster foreigns in Jamaica
by the way,
because it's a big Christian.
The Christians invaded that place and
just fucking turned everybody into
dogmatic fucking thinking people to
judo.
You know the what the white man does
everywhere across the planet.
You got to be my religion.
Fuck everybody else.
This is what's up.
So they did that dad.
So I'm what they call the Jamaicans.
What the rosters called the Jamaicans
who don't grow knots.
They call them ball heads,
man.
You know,
like Bob Marley,
crazy ball head.
So what they did with these guys,
uh,
a,
a cop tried to kill Ross,
the foreign and the roster foreign
killed a cop so they put a bounty on
every single Rastafari and wanted dead
or alive.
You could kill a roster and drag him to
the precinct and collect a reward.
So all the rosters fled up into the
hills and it was called the Greenbay
killings.
They just started killing all these
rastafarian's it.
And so this guy brought me up into the
hills and I met these rosters and the
Nyabinghi,
the drummers and all that shit.
And the guy had the actual,
because it was only like two,
maybe three years prior to me going
there in 1980 and I got to meet like
these cats that survived that shit.
And they had the news and all this shit.
So that was like my first experience
with the whole roster thing.
And then I met the bad brains one night
at first Ian Mci and all them cats came
down with teenagers and untouchables.
That was Henry's whole crew first.
I know Henry's been on here,
I'm pretty good friends with him and our
next week tell him I said,
well,
started fucking love him man.
He's a fucking great human being.
He's a beast.
And yeah,
he was like,
when I split the baby he let me stay at
his house and I was eating his food and
then after a week of him going to work
and coming home and his food's gone.
He's like,
all right,
John,
you gotta,
get the fuck out.
Go somewhere.
Not here.
But uh,
they played and then a week later,
uh,
I used to go during the middle of the
day,
uh,
in my car in the navy and go to happy
hour and I'm walking in and the owner
comes out.
He's like,
you got to shoot this fucking band.
You got to see this band.
I'm like,
all right,
cool.
I'm going in.
He's like,
no,
you don't understand their fucking black
man and there.
They're incredible.
So I go upstairs and bad brains are
sound checking and I'm just like,
what the fuck is this?
And if you haven't seen the bad brains,
I'll tell you the best video to watch.
Nineteen 80 to cbgbs they got the whole
set up there.
And if you want to have your shit blown
away,
just watch that.
So that's what,
uh,
I actually sold their,
their manager acid.
I was selling acid at the time.
So they manage.
I sold him acid,
but I got to talk with her and he
started telling me about this pma shit.
And,
and I told him,
hey man,
I fucking got out of jail and went into
the navy because I caught another case.
They offer me military.
Here we go.
Is them right?
They're fucking amazing dude.
Will this get us taken off Youtube,
you think?
Yeah.
Sing.
And he's a fucking maniac.
He does a back flip perfectly on the end
of this one song at the movies and lands
it perfectly.
That's CBS in 82.
Wow.
I wasn't there.
I was their roadie.
I was in high school.
Yeah.
So I was actually living as a Hari
Krishna monk at the time in Hawaii.
When?
When,
so how did the Howard Kristen thing?
Well,
I'm going to tell you.
Okay.
So what happened was,
um,
they had,
so I talked with her,
he said,
yeah man,
it was really funny because they were
all from DC,
but they talk with Patois accent.
Yeah.
Mine jogging arranged mine.
We're going to run into,
to each other again,
you know.
So,
uh,
I beat someone down on my shit pretty
bad and I got caught for a drug case in
Norfolk,
so I knew that they was trying to
persecute me and uh,
you know,
sent me to fucking prison and I was like
really not going to have that.
So my ship pulled out and we will go
into like shell back to South America.
And um,
I had,
this day I was on the,
you know,
basically under arrest because the
fight,
it was civilian case for the drugs.
I sold to an undercover cop outside of a
club called King's head in Norfork on
Hampton Boulevard was dead,
did punk shows.
So I sold him a,
you know,
Lsd,
and he was an undercover cop so I got
arrested for that and then that was
pending.
Meanwhile,
I go on my shit,
we go out to see this one redneck kept
fucking with me and he was like,
Fuck Eve,
New York faggot.
And like,
just,
I'm like,
dude,
chill,
like you don't know me,
like I'm not fucking with you.
Just let it go man.
And he just wouldn't let it go.
So,
uh,
I trapped them in the paint lock up.
I was supposed to meet and I beat him
with a fucking paint can in the soft
tissues till he shit his pants.
Then they arrested me.
So they had,
uh,
they had me on the fucking ships arrest
and all this shit and I'm,
I got this bad infection.
They had to medevac me off the ship,
back to Roosevelt roads,
Puerto Rico.
And they forgot to say that,
you know,
I'm supposed to be handcuffed to the
fucking bed.
And then,
uh,
they cut.
They didn't send those orders because
this was pre computer.
So the paperwork I fucked up,
they gave me my id and then they sent me
back to Norfolk and then,
uh,
I was just doing all my shit.
And so they just didn't know that you're
supposed to be incarcerated.
They didn't know that I'm supposed to be
awaiting court,
poppy,
court marshal,
whatever the fuck.
And then the civilian case too.
So then,
uh,
I was inimitable,
which is Tpu,
transient personnel union waiting for my
ship to come back and they were going to
deal with it then.
So I was there for like,
I dunno,
like a month and a half.
And,
and they were like,
Yo,
your ship.
The dude I was cool with,
he warned me.
He goes,
Yo,
your ship is fucking talking today.
And I was like,
fuck.
I was like,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
So I just packed up a couple of things
and I got on the bus that used to go
through the base and then roll out
Hampton Boulevard.
And as I'm fucking day I had already
pulled in.
And as I'm pulling out the gate in the
seat,
the fucking master at arms of my ship,
the police are right there walking
across the street to fucking them.
It's all to get me.
And I just shrunk,
shrunk down in the seat.
But if they would've looked up,
that was it,
I wouldn't be here telling you this
story because my life would have taken a
much different trajectory.
So what happened was I went up and I
hitchhiked with his band,
the undead from New York.
This punk band,
bobby
bobby still was an original misfits.
So they,
they played the 9:30 and they gave me a
ride back to New York and I get out the
van and right there on avenue a one 71
was motherfucking h on the doorway with
a recorded and lived.
He's like Ross stuff far.
I'm like fuck.
And what happened was they were playing
a show a couple of days later and
there's a big Puerto Rican gang that was
right there that didn't want them
hanging out.
So they went in there one night and
they,
I mean they,
they killed people.
I'm not going to say the name of the,
of the fucking gang because for
whatever,
you know,
I'm not trying to out him like that.
But they were,
had the largest heroin cocaine spot in
America.
The feds busted,
busted them knock down there building
the whole shit.
Alphabet city was out of fucking
control.
So nobody.
The beastie boys were there that night.
Nobody would fight these dudes back.
And I was on a fucking qualia,
which is gorilla biscuits.
You think you got crazy strength and uh,
I said to j Dot Lee,
who was the engineer that shit.
I was like,
Yo,
let's get these motherfuckers man.
And he's like,
dude,
they kill people.
Don't fuck with them.
They will kill you.
And I was like,
Yo,
come on,
you fucking do your punk rock is
supposed to be fucking tough.
Let's fucking get these guys.
So they calmed me down.
But when I got outside,
the dude tried to stab me.
So I blocked the knife and I hit him
with an elbow and pop out.
Bob knocked him down,
smashed his head off the curb.
Next thing I know,
four of his homies come charging at me.
Yo,
you white motherfucker trying to stab
me.
And I used to wear a chain belt and you
can ask Henry.
We all used to wear these chain belts
with a quick release,
a bike chain to fight people because in
dc it would be the marines would fucking
or the rednecks would beat up the punk
rockers.
So I got in a fight with these
motherfuckers and I ended up,
so I go to run back into one 71 because
I lost the chain and one of the beastie
boys slams,
tries to slam the door.
I mean it keeps me out on the street.
These motherfuckers want to kill me.
I pushed my way in.
I got stabbed in the shoulder and then
they put out a kol on me.
They were like,
we're going to kill that motherfucker.
Nobody would hang out with me except for
this one crazy Russian street fighter
kid named James Concert.
That's the only dude.
So then I said I couldn't go down the
alphabet city at all.
They were waiting there with fucking
guns and bats and like,
we're going to kill that dude.
But because the bad brains were black,
they kind of squashed it over.
But I went up there to face him and they
surrounded me like fucking dude was like
ready to fucking off me and doc and
Darryl Docs,
the guitar player,
the Bass player came running out,
Yo,
Yo chill,
chill.
And they were like,
you know,
he was just,
standing up like y'all came in,
they're trying to stab everybody.
You would have done the same shit.
And the one dude's name was crazy eddie.
And uh,
he got,
I think he got murdered now,
but he did mad time and he just looked
at me and it was that moment or this
standoff where I didn't know what the
fuck he was going to do,
but he just goes out to all the white
motherfuckers over here.
You're the only one with heart.
We ain't never gonna fuck with y'all
again.
Just don't hang out outside the store
front because there was gigs at one 71
a.
that's where bad play beastie boys.
And then the bad brains let me move in.
And then they recorded our first album,
which MCA for the bad brains.
Greatest Hardcore punk album of all
time.
The Rock has set the lightning bolt.
Smith.
I was there for the whole recording and
uh,
then they got me a job and this is where
the Christian thing comes in.
I always,
I always come full circle.
But uh,
so this punk band named the dots who put
out the first bad brains,
single Jimmy quit was in a band and he
put out a single quote,
stay close to me and pay to come and
vinny work that this health food store.
So they started giving us food and
that's when I started changing over to
the Diet because bad brains were like,
you.
Hr would be like,
you don't eat the fuckery.
You don't eat the Babylon food.
You got to eat it.
I tell is vitas can be fatal.
Took me to the hell it is.
I tell it means pure,
pure plant based food.
No,
no oil,
no fucking salt.
It's like oil.
Yeah.
Dude.
This district,
it's like the avocado oil.
Coconut oil.
No,
like if you take coconut and you and you
fucking shred it down so fine at the oil
comes out of it,
that's fine.
But they don't do processed oils.
That's a different thing when you
process the oil.
If you have health problems like what
they proved in forks over knives,
then it becomes a toxic oil to the body
and if you have any kind of heart
conditions and stuff like that,
you should be really avoided.
So anyway,
what they did was they got me,
they were smart because they wanted me
to give them free food,
the bad brains,
and they got me in the health food store
and the dude was like,
this hippie Yogi dude hooked up with
Satchidananda Swami.
It was called Pronto foods.
And he's like,
well,
you're going to do Karma Yoga when you
first come in here.
In other words,
you're not going to get any money.
You're going gonna,
you know you can eat and it's Karma Yoga
is good for your Karma.
So then I told everybody in the
motherfucking neighborhood,
I was like,
Yo,
I'm working at this health food store.
Come over and get some food.
So bad brains would come and load up
groceries.
I worked at juice bars given our fuck
sandwiches didn't.
Entire neighborhood due to sit there
watching me and after the end of the day
he goes,
excuse me,
did,
did any of those people pay for that
food?
I go,
Nah,
man,
that's that Karma Yoga Shit you talking
to me about.
He's like,
you're on salary as a tomorrow,
do not give away any more food.
So then I was like,
I worked there for a little while and
vinny took me to the Hari Krishna Temple
on 55th street.
So I kept trying to defeat this dude.
Philosophically.
I was like,
Yo.
But,
and he knew the whole philosophy of the
Vedas and the Bhagavad Gita is where all
the yoga
or the yoga sutras and all of that comes
out of the Bhagavad Gita and prob.
I put out the Bhagavad Gita as it is,
which,
which the original Bhagavad Gita from
India.
And uh,
I kept trying to defeat it all the time.
Every day I read Bhagavad gita stream on
bog of the time.
What do you think?
Who Soma?
What's does Salma Salma Ross?
So morass that is a drink that they
drink on the heavenly planets.
It's a,
it's a beverage on a heavily planets
that they get in toxic intoxicated.
The big question is like,
what's in it?
No one knows.
There's elements.
You know when people say you didn't use
lying on the planets.
I'm like,
what are you fucking Momma Luke?
Of course there's life on other.
You think you're the only fucking life
in the universe.
Come on,
man.
Well,
that's one of the things in the Bhagavad
Gita is a flying crafts and Soma is one
of them.
Someone's one of the interesting things
rather and Soma,
they.
It's some sort of a psychedelic
concoction,
but nobody knows exactly what it is.
They think it might be a combination of
several things.
They think for sure psilocybins in it,
but they think it might also be hashish
that has.
She might be in it.
Yeah.
I mean there's elements in the,
in the upper planetary system that
Brahmaloka and all these different
planets in the solar.
The vedic astrology is much different
than the western astrology,
so they talk about planets way above
earth.
You know that,
what they're teaching you,
the Bhagavad Gita,
the.
What do they describe Soma,
so like what are they called it Soma
Ross,
and it was a beverage that's drunk in
the heavenly planets.
It's not available on the earth planet
is is the demi gods drink soma,
Ross demigods on,
on other planets.
That's the only time people drink it.
She did she bite,
smoke the Ganja and stuff like that and
I don't know,
you know,
they put the ashes to the crematorium on
their bodies and stuff like that.
But they,
you know,
the thing about,
there's four principles in the Hari
Krishna when you live as a Brahmin monk,
which I did,
and it's no intoxication at all.
No,
no eating of meat,
fish,
eggs,
none of that.
No gambling and no.
We'll listed sex.
So I was actually a 100 percent brahma
choice celibate monk for how long?
For two years.
And I trained martial arts in Hawaii and
the hills with this one black dude who
was fucking fierce and he was a Brahmin
Shari too.
So we would train and completely
celebrate.
I was getting up 2:00 every single day
in the morning.
I was in bed by eight and training and
working and just,
you know,
trying to heal my,
uh,
my assault.
But that came because when I first was
going to the temple I wrote,
I would write down my questions.
I know I'm going to get these
motherfuckers tomorrow because I was
reading Gorgie,
Krishnamurti Rom dots.
Like I studied it.
I know I saw all those guys.
Uh,
I went to see a krishnamurthy speak and
meditate.
I was,
I was just eating it up.
Like once that light came on a
metaphysically for the meditation and
the Yoga and everything,
I just went full bore into it.
So it started from the health food
store?
Yeah,
because store mini signal rally who's
now the drummer for the unsane.
He still plays drums.
He was in the dots.
He was in turbo hydromatic.
It's a bunch of bands in New York and he
just started hitting me with questions.
What do you think?
This is what he thinks.
I was like,
I don't know man.
And then after giving me this book,
He gave me this book called the science
of self realization.
And I read it and I was like,
dude,
this Yoga Master Ac Bhaktivedanta Swami
Pot.
I was like,
I got to find out more.
Whereas this guy,
and he said,
oh,
he left the planet in [inaudible] 77,
but you could go to the temple and see
the whole process.
I was like,
Yo,
I want to call.
And I went and they had this ceremony
and it's called greeting as a dds.
And then the song that gets played,
George Harrison plays Bass on it and I
was like,
Yo,
it was from the promise some heater.
And I was.
I just was attracted to it.
Everything I've known in my life was
pain and violence and just fucking
crazy.
I mean,
you know,
so it was a pathway to some sort of an
escape from the Pr,
the trappings of your past.
It was a pathway to enlightenment.
It was a pathway to peace.
Absolutely piece.
But some of the most fierce warriors.
And what I loved about Bhagavad Gita is
spoken on a battlefield between
Christian on Juno.
Juno was [inaudible] Krishna's this
line,
this,
this sound pro diet comes from the
warrior class.
And if you read any books on martial
arts,
they're going to tell you the martial
arts originated in India,
the original martial arts school.
We're all in India and at one point
Sanccob charia chased all the Buddhists
out of India and they fled across the
Himalayas into China.
So this is actual history that you and
you can see where the martial arts
spread out across across the planet,
but you know,
a lot of it,
uh,
a lot of things that are around today
originated in India.
So to me that really,
I was always in,
you know,
I was a street fighter.
I messed around,
uh,
even,
you know,
with some going to martial arts schools,
always on the outskirts.
I even went and trained with Ron van
Cleef when he had his school in New
York.
But yeah,
but he would,
he would always be trained in police
forces.
And I was the only white dude in the
class and it was all black and Puerto
Rican.
And when it came time to spot,
they beat the shit out of me.
I was getting fucking wrecked by the,
by the black belts.
Byb,
uh,
you know,
I was no lights barnbrook then.
No nobody water.
There was schools,
victim Vega,
Ron van Cleef,
Ron Tag,
and now she does do doc,
uh,
this other dude named Rodin who ran the
school,
University of streets,
they would run from into the Dojo like
20 dudes and just all out fucking Bra.
Like even Brian Callahan,
his teacher and all these guys,
they train under master Choi and some
them joy and he encouraged you to fight.
You are training to fight.
Like
it was very common back then.
That was a big part of it because you
had to develop people that could
actually perform in competition and one
of the best ways to do that was deaf
challenge matches.
So like what you're talking about,
smokers,
they used to allow that in la up until
real recently,
over the last 10 years or so,
they banned smokers but used to be able
to get your experience in actual fights,
the smoker and that was a little bit
more prepared than the Dojo storming
days.
But the Dojo stormy days,
that's how a lot of people go.
Good.
And said like,
you have real fights,
he would go in there,
some guy would come from another school
and you knew you going to hit each other
as hard as you could.
It wasn't.
It wasn't really sparring.
Well,
I'll tell you a lot of that spun into
gang bonds too because a lot of people
that were the martial arts teacher,
this one dude jr,
he's famous.
He was in the New York Times.
He was one of the biggest heroin
traffickers on the lower east side.
He was one of the first guys to get
busted onto the rico statute.
He did the full 25 and he trained all of
the dudes as Sol for him and all his
street soldiers were all trained in
martial arts.
So a lot of these guys were doing shady
shit behind the scenes because that's
what alphabet city in the lower east
side and that's what New York was about.
I'm actually good friends with tae mock
time mark in the last dragon time.
Mocks father is a Christian.
His name is cosmo.
I met him in La like fucking 20 years
ago.
He came to a show,
I was like,
that's the last dragon.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
he,
I won't say names,
but he out is somebody that tried to do
some shit to him in and they blackballed
him in Hollywood and the guy say,
you're never going to make another
motherfucking movie,
and he hasn't.
He got fucking dude.
He that happen a whole cogan.
Somebody tried to fuck Hulk Hogan.
Yeah.
Imagine a giant human being.
I was like,
I'm going to suck your Dick.
And he's like,
no brother.
Real step up to the slim.
This is like this Terry Cruz thing or a
lot of people made fun of Terry crews
because how does this big stud of an
athlete,
who cares if who grabs your Dick just
swat that guy in the head,
but he's saying,
no,
this is a.
This is a system systemic problem.
When you have people that are in power
and they control your destiny and that's
where a lot of that they'll ruin you may
have.
And they did.
A lot of people
listen like the whole like,
you know the whole me too.
Shit.
First of all,
my mother was raped twice,
so if some dude is pushing his weight
around a on a on a female,
I think that Shit's fucked up and then
they're going to turn around and fucking
fuck these people.
I say,
fucking get him the fuck added here and
I'm going to tell you a story because
I'm Julia Phillips and Michael Phillips
date.
They've fucking produced one of my
favorite movies of all time,
which was taxi driver and close
encounters.
They did all those movies.
She wrote a book called,
you'll never do lunch in this town
again.
In the eighties.
She had the cro mags come and play in a
movie at the rich.
They flew us off the motorhead tour,
picked us up in limos.
She wanted to shit to be lip song.
I said,
now if you want the cro mags is a
fucking real show and we're going to
fucking lay it down.
We had like a thousand of our fans.
They will tape do just crazy shit.
And two people broke their necks during
the shooting.
So the movie's called.
It's called the beat.
Yeah.
But the thing was,
she was one of the first people to put
out an expose these fucking scumbags for
doing that shit to people in Hollywood
exposed a lot of that in a book that you
never do lunch in his town again.
And when the book came out she was on
the set for interview with a vampire and
they came and pulled it off the set and
she was fucking blackballed from fucking
Hollywood.
She never made any more fucking movies.
And then even pre internet,
this was pre internet and get away with
things like that.
But she just fucking put up the middle
finger to all of them.
Like,
fuck you.
She,
she passed away of cancer.
But she was like a real fucking punk
rock a man she fucking took on the
system,
the boy's Club in Hollywood.
And you know,
even the shit,
I don't know how legit decore filming,
you know,
stuff is.
I know him and whatever.
But like she's saying
problem that you don't.
Yeah.
It's one of those things where I don't
know what to do.
Yes,
there's some shenanigans,
but I know that it's something happened.
Yeah,
I know it,
I know it goes on,
something happens,
not just him.
I mean the list is a mile long and for
everybody that comes forth is a million
people that are sitting back on,
I don't want to say anything because I
don't want to take that shame on.
Well,
that's what happened with me.
You know,
it was the same day like,
uh,
you know,
you have this wrapping,
whatever the fuck,
but that's all false ego.
Even all of that stuff.
And then the person that I was with at
the time said,
you know,
this story is going to help a lot of
people you by you coming forward and
saying what happened to you and how
you're dealing with it now.
And that's what,
that's what I even did.
I got this new book,
the PMA effect coming out and the whole
shit is about healing people and help.
I mean,
I've helped thousands of people kicked
drugs,
kick a suicidal thoughts.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
it's not that I'm like,
I'm turning him into a Vegan.
It's like,
dude,
I'm going to show you the system that
worked for me.
That's all I can do is tell you,
I'm like the fucking mailman,
you know,
I'm just delivering the fucking mail to
you.
I didn't come up with it,
but I'm showing you the yoga to plant
based diet,
to meditation,
to training,
constantly fucking training.
Well through all the things you're
doing,
you're committed and you're,
you're disciplined and that's attractive
to people,
right?
People look to for people that are doing
things that they wish they were doing,
so they see someone.
I mean that's the whole cult of
personality,
right?
They see you,
they see you,
you've got this powerful personality and
your positive and you're doing
things and people gravitate to that and
they want to be a part of that.
I mean that's,
that's what happens with people,
but the first thing that I,
and I said it because vice did a whole
18 minutes special on me.
If you,
if you just google a fucking a Vegan
iron man,
this shit comes up.
They did an 18 minute documentary and
one of the things I said,
first off,
don't say you can't do it.
You could do any fucking thing.
You apply yourself too,
you just haven't tried.
You could do what I'm doing and I'm
going to tell you I go to racist,
these iron mans all over the fucking
world and these guys show me pitches.
One guy was fucking.
He lost 100 fucking pounds.
Dude was so depressed.
He was on meds for depression,
so everything that I'm doing is coming
at a service.
It's service to help people.
It's not.
I come at them right from the same
fucking platform I'm like,
and even the Vedas,
what does it say?
Not a piece.
Han and throw money down an idea Yaka.
Danielle said that,
hurry.
You should think of yourself lower than
destroying the street,
more tolerant than a tree.
Always ready to offer respect to others.
In that state of mind,
one can constantly chant the holy names
of Hari Krishna.
So that's the philosophy.
So where is the false ego?
And thinking,
I'm better than you because I eat a
motherfucking vegetable and you eat a
fucking piece of meat or whatever.
It's not about that.
It's about trying to help people and
have compassion to people and that's
something that's really getting lost in
this world is compassion.
Everybody wants to kick people when
they're down and I just don't understand
where this fucking sickness came from
it.
And I think a lot of it has to do with
reality TV and this whole microwave,
insta fame fucking culture that exists
now.
It's like what you said,
they think that if,
if they put down somebody that's going
to make,
they're going to gain power from it.
It's like,
it's just crazy.
I don't come from that.
I come from like,
Yo,
man,
let's help one another to make this
world a better place.
How are we going to save the oceans?
How are we going to save?
You know,
and you know,
my thing is this,
look,
they just said that the,
the fucking commercial meat and dairy
industries are now the most toxic.
Uh,
they're the most toxic of companies on
the fucking planet.
They just surpassed fossil fuel with the
destruction they're doing to the planet.
So I'm like,
eat a little less news is coming from it
just I just,
it's,
it was just all on.
Where did I read it?
It was on,
uh,
one of the main sites like that.
So is this by a,
from methane gas as a from fossil fuels
runoff.
Look,
here's,
here's the thing.
So before that Gulf oil spill ever
happened,
there was a fucking dead zone in the
Gulf of Mexico,
the size of New Jersey.
Why all the fucking run off of the
[inaudible] and the farms with the
fucking toxic pesticides,
the fucking,
all this shit that these guys are
spraying roundup and everything else.
And,
and the nitrogen that's in the fucking
shit when these lagoons that have
100,000 fucking gallons of pig shit,
you know,
it all was draining into,
into the Mississippi and then draining
into the Gulf.
So if you look at what's going on in
North Carolina right now,
because I was just there,
motherfuckers can't even swim in the
rivers anymore.
And it's happening in Europe too.
They just had to cancel the swim on the
Iron Ironman in,
in Homburg because of the green allergy
and all this shit that's happening now
because of all the runoff that's
happening with the farms and everything
is just we're.
We're making this planet of fucking
toxic wasteland
we've done with farms and it's gotten.
We developed cities.
We have giant groups of people that are
growing anything and then we give people
incentive to make as much profit as
possible and when they're trying to make
as much profit as possible without
ethics or morals and consideration are
or the impact on the environment.
They set off a process in motion that we
are many,
many decades into right now.
So to try to correct it.
Now we're just seeing the effects and
then on top of that there's all these ag
gag laws and that gag laws are
devastating because when you see.
Like one of the reasons I became a
hunter is because I was watching these
films of factory farming and I was like,
I'm not.
I'm not participating in this.
I have to figure out what I'm going to
do.
I'm either going to become a vegetarian
or I'm going to become a hunter.
I decided to become a hunter and that's
how I get my meat,
but when you see those videos,
those are the videos that expose people
to the realities and the horrors of
factory farming and those are illegal in
most places.
Yeah.
You go to prison now you go to federal
for showing horrible,
immoral acts that are done to these
animals and the way they're treated and
the way they're contained,
and we were talking yesterday about this
video of a pig farm that there's this,
there's this pig farm where these pigs
are smashed into this place where they
can't move at all.
They're all in these cases and then
it's.
There's a runoff from where they shit
and piss and there's a giant lake
outside of pig shit and pig pis and no
one who lives anywhere near that could
avoid that smell.
You drive anywhere near that area.
It's a horrific toxic smell,
so it's already gotten to this almost
like incorrect double position like
that,
that that business is a toxic business,
but it's not a regular like a Joel
Salitan farm.
You know what?
That guy has never heard of him.
He runs this farm called polyface farms
and what he does is he has all these
animals live like normal animals,
like the pigs,
they're not in these cages.
He has them roam free and they set.
They set up these enormous portable
fences,
so they take the pigs,
they roam in this one area like pigs
naturally do,
and then they moved the fence to a
different area and they transport.
They did move the pigs over with it,
so the pigs are never contained.
The chickens run free and then they go
back into the chicken house at night and
then they try not to have mono.
Like when you have,
when you have a thousand acres of
soybeans,
that shit ain't normal.
That's not how plants are supposed to
be,
and then you have to throw pesticides on
them and then when you roll them up,
you have to grind everything up.
But these gigantic machines and
everything gets caught up in their mice
and rabbits and everything that might be
in the,
in the neighborhood while these machines
are rolling over.
All of that is unnatural and it's not
how human beings are supposed to grow
food.
It's not food is supposed to be.
Some of these plants or animals are
supposed to be interacting with the
environment.
But what we're doing with these things
is making an incredible amounts of
profit.
And these people are addicted to this
These corporations are addicted.
These profit,
they have this constant growth mentality
where every year,
every quarter has to have more.
It's a never ending.
And they make the laws.
And the only way,
the other thing,
well,
they have massive amounts of money.
So they bribe politicians and they use
all of these,
uh,
these lobbyists.
And what they do is they get these laws
passed where it's illegal to film them
doing immoral shit.
And so then you don't see this,
you just go to the store and you buy a
cheeseburger,
you go to Jack in the box,
you go wherever you go,
and you buy these things,
you get corn,
you know where you get corn Syrup in
your soda,
you don't think twice about what,
what has to happen for that corn to
become syrup and how much environmental
damage has to take place.
I mean this is the world we're living in
right now is just waking up to what has
been in motion for many,
many decades.
I think what's really important though
is that we're honest about health and
they were honest about the consequences
of our actions in terms of like our
purchasing power,
what we're doing with food.
We got to be honest about all of it.
And one of the problems that happens
with hunters are carnivores or even
vegans or vegetarians,
is people only want to look at things
that support their position.
And with Vegans,
there's a lot of people out there that
only want to look at things that support
Vegan positions in terms of health.
And this becomes a real problem because
they start,
they start using studies that are very
shaky,
they start adding things to
documentaries that aren't necessarily
true or proven and it becomes propaganda
and it becomes propaganda both ways.
I see what this carnivore diet now,
there's a lot of people that would this
carnivore diet that are like,
this is the only way to go,
you know,
just eat all meat.
And I'm like,
man,
I don't know about all that.
I don't see any blood work.
I see blood work only I talked to.
Um,
uh,
Sean,
what is his last name?
Sean?
The doctor.
Goddammit.
Fuck.
He's the main carnivore guy.
How can I not remember his name?
What is,
how,
how's that slipping?
My,
my Sean Baker,
Sean Being Sean Baker,
he released his blood work.
It's not good.
It's blood.
Work's not good.
Testosterone's low.
There's also all sorts of.
And I just want to say,
uh,
who were the Haas?
Let's just look at it this way.
Who are the hospitals filled with that
are having procedures for bypass?
Who were the procedures
being done for people?
Removing your limbs for diabetes is not
the people that it's the people that are
eating this toxic diet that Americans to
the standard American diet and what
people have become accustomed to eating,
rolling up,
and even these carnival people.
Let's just take that for instance,
if you do all meet sure your body let
that motherfucker might've been on a
Dorito Diet.
We don't know what the fuck he was
eating prior prior to that.
So then you put the bodies a perfect
machine so it at the beginning of when
you're doing all meet,
the body's become accustomed to that,
but you know the analogy that I use is
that's like getting off heroin and
getting on Methadone because the
methadone,
Yo,
I kicked dope when I'm on fucking meth
now because the method on down the road
is going to take even a longer tool and
I've seen people that are doing
methadone for 20,
30 years and that's why I love the
analogy because the long term studies of
those diets do not exist right now.
No,
there's no longterm studies for the
current,
but if you look at the blue zones around
the planet of the people who were the
most centurions and the people that live
the longest,
they have three things in common.
Okay.
And there's,
there's blue zones in Japan,
Costa Rica,
grease around the United States while
the top five,
uh,
with the most and then,
and then California.
And it's the adventist seventh day
adventists.
So the three things that they have most
in common with the people that live the
longest.
Number one,
they have a meditation,
spiritual practice.
They do something every day for pma,
positive mental attitude,
whatever their higher power is,
they do that every day.
Number two,
they moved their bodies.
They're working,
they work in the farm,
they're exercising.
Number three,
they eat primarily a plant based diet.
They may have a piece of fish in Japan
or whatever,
or a piece of meat once in awhile,
but primarily the seven day adventist
study was actually the best one because
it was all from different people with
different ethnic backgrounds.
And the one thing that they had in
common,
the seven day adventists don't eat meat.
And uh,
that's my point with the whole thing and
you know,
when it comes down to diet is I just see
what,
what worked for me and I try to relay
that to people and not not be like my
way's the only way and this and that
because people,
people doing other people are doing
other things,
uh,
in their way.
There's raw foodist is all these
different people.
And the problem is with the false ego in
a human being,
everybody wants to think that the class
is full.
Don't try to tell me Shit.
I know it all.
Here's an issue with centurions,
the centurions century.
Aaron's centenarians,
centenarians,
centenarians.
Yeah.
Um,
people that lived to be 100 years
is one thing we have to take into
consideration.
You're talking about people that lived
already to be 100 years.
So when they were 50 was 50 years ago.
All right,
we're talking about 1967.
Nobody knew shit about diet back then.
This is the fact that,
okay,
so the people that did live that long
and they were living this,
it's almost a,
an accident in some ways are
inconsequential.
Like what?
What is going on today with people's
Diet and how long will people live too.
There's far more information in terms of
nutrition and what you should do and
shouldn't do for your body.
So what I'm concerned with is like what
optimizes people today.
I want to see blood work.
I want to see like what is going on with
your blood lipids,
what is going on with your nutrient
levels,
what is going on with that?
And in that case we don't have.
We have just a few studies from a few
people or if you test from a few people
that have done this carnivore diet,
we have some people that have done the
Vegan diet and have had real hard
problems with that.
Yeah,
but let's just.
Let me just say one thing,
because to throw the word Vegan on
something that does not make it a
healthy diet.
I know Reagan's data fucking 100 pounds
overweight.
They eat nothing but fried chicken
pizza.
You say in organic whole food,
plant based Diet.
That's what I roll with,
right?
I don't.
I don't fucking say I took a Vegan diet
can mean anything,
but when you say whole food foods in
their original source,
organic,
no pesticides,
whole food,
plant based Diet.
That's what I roll with,
so that's why I don't go around.
Nutrient dense mineral dense and the
minerals mineral dense
with people that live a long time.
One of the things that you get from a
lot of plants,
especially like rich green leafy plants,
you get a lot of minerals.
Absolutely,
and more importantly if these things are
raised in an organic environment,
you're getting soil that's not depleted
and this is a big problem with model.
Did you see the article that just came
out today that 40 years ago and orange
was 10 times more and more nutritious?
I think it was.
I think it might've been CNN online or
something.
They posted an article that said the
fruits and vegetables from 40 years ago
were 10 times more nutritious than the
than the way they're being grown today
because like you said,
rows and rows and rows.
That makes sense.
How do they extract the nutrients
properly from the soil?
It's impossible.
Well,
you know,
they have to actually add nutrients to
the soil.
Most of the time it just adding nitrogen
and a few other different minerals,
but
pig shit.
Like what?
What they do is to get.
How did they get rid of that pig shit.
They're spraying it on the fucking crops
and you know,
well you're.
You're supposed to rotate crops in
rotation.
What you plant next to each other that
are extra.
I'm not a farmer composting,
but I have a friend that is an organic
farmer and his name,
his name is Keith and he farms up in New
Hampshire and he knows all about crop
rotation as Keith Leon Forte.
If you have to do,
you can do it.
That's what he does.
He has a small farm.
The small farms are legit.
Like you can have a small farm and be in
symbiosis,
so like you could be in harmony with the
land,
but man,
you're starting,
you're growing,
you know,
fucking a thousand acres of corn for
cattle feed.
There's,
you might as well be making oil.
Well,
I mean you're,
you're,
you're doing something that's kind of
crazy,
that environment.
It's not natural.
And,
and,
and listen,
you know,
I saw a Ted knew Jim play with fucking
ACDC and Black Sabbath and 76 at Madison
Square Garden.
I went to all them shows,
but you know,
when he came on and the shit that he was
talking,
I was just like the fucking gmo crops.
Okay.
Eighty percent of the GMO crop is being
fed to animals for fucking slaughter to
the,
what he called to stupid vegans are not
the ones that are eating that shit that
most of the crops that are genetically
modified,
because you have these corporations,
Mcdonald's,
every one of these corporations,
they want every fucking piece of meat.
It tastes the same.
They want every fucking French fries,
potato to be the same.
So the only way they can control it is
the control of the genetic markers.
So that's why they're using all of the,
all the majority of the genetically
modified grains.
And Monsanto,
uh,
you know,
who just got bought out by bear and
they're changing the name because
Monsanto is such a big rap rap rap.
If you don't know it,
bear just bought them.
Now,
do you know the history of bear from
surgical company?
No,
but no.
Prior to that they made this cast that
went into the Nazi death chambers.
Well that's,
you know what's funny,
that nightclub,
cyclops gas was created by Fritz Haber.
Fritz harbor is also the guy who created
the process of extracting nitrogen from
the air.
Really?
So he's the guy.
The reason why we can grow the crops
that we have today is because of Fritz
harbor.
They say that 50 percent of the nitrogen
and the nitrogen and most people's DNA
comes from the harbor method.
He also created cycle on a,
on a client,
be the Nazis.
Well,
he created cycle on a and they added
this smell to it so that you could smell
this toxic gas.
You would know it when it was coming so
you can get out of the way.
The Nazis switched to design B.
Fritz Harbor was actually a Jew and they
took his invention and cut out the smell
portion of it so that they could gas
Jews with
dark shit.
I said,
Joseph Smart motherfucker.
I'm learning today.
It's dark shit,
but bob or method
saved a lot of people and killed a lot
of people.
They wanted to try that guy for crimes
against humanity while he was winning
the Nobel Prize for science at the same
time as he was also the first people.
He was one of the first people that
implemented a gassing program where they
used it,
the gas,
the allied troops in World War One.
That was.
Wow.
That was a big part of that.
I didn't.
I did not know that.
Yeah,
it's crazy shit.
So that is how we get nitrogen.
We get nitrogen from the harbor method
when they're poor nitrogen into the
plant,
into the soil.
So they can grow plants.
That's a big part of it.
When you say genetically modified to
the,
a big part of that is like we want to
think about,
oh like labs and science and all this
jazz,
but almost everything we eat is
genetically modified including all of
our grains.
Like especially all of our fruits and
vegetables.
We were saying about tomatoes or
orange being different than it was 10
years ago.
Fucking everything's different because
they want these things to be durable so
they could throw them in a bus or a
truck rather than travel close to
French.
Well here's the thing,
and I know what they do.
They take the DNA of a flounder and
injected into tomatoes so it can resist
the fraud.
How the fuck did they do?
I don't fucking know.
It's.
That's real.
So if you eat a tomato,
does it have flounder right now?
Vegans?
If you're eating GMO shit,
maybe you're not eating Vegan food.
You could be eating a fish.
Tomato thing
is if you eat plants,
plants absorb like you.
They've found salmon DNA in some plants
because plants absorb this fish thing
that people use for fertilizer.
Yeah,
no.
So you're getting some of that animal,
but it's a natural cycle that you're
getting it through.
I mean,
animals eat animals,
plants eat animals,
animals,
even eat plants.
I mean this is fucking crazy plants in
South America.
It looks like a,
like a vase and these rats,
they get attracted this sweet smell
around the edges and it's slick and they
fall into the hole and the plant closes
in and swallows them and eats them.
Yeah.
Well,
well,
you know,
the other thing is this,
you have chemical companies making you
food.
Their job is not to feed the world,
not to keep you healthy.
Their job is to sell fucking pesticides.
Let's,
let's be fucking straight up about it.
So yeah,
they created.
What was the other,
across a genetic.
There's a,
there's a,
uh,
a vegetable,
I think it was brought up.
Was it cauliflower?
Broccoli?
They mixed two things and came out with
a.
it's a different process.
What they're doing now and really what
they do when they can take roundup and
pesticides and put it in the fucking
seed,
right,
is what they're doing now.
And
so the plant from the growth cycle is
resistant to these brands
and,
and all the people that have in the gut
issues.
I don't know if you listen,
you know,
I know you had rich roll on twice.
He's my boy.
He's a homie dude.
He's fucking.
Everyone asked me like what's time
motherfucker life and what's he like in
real life.
I'm like,
that's the most genuine fucking dude,
you know,
you ever have anything going on?
He just wrote the forward to my new
book,
the PMA effect.
I mean,
he's such a fucking.
He's a solid cat.
Very solid.
But um,
where was I going with that?
You took me down to plans.
Glyphosate.
Yeah.
So he just had Dr Zach Bush.
Come on.
Who's a doctor?
This is clinical research.
This is not speculation.
This is not fucking Vegan propaganda.
This is fucking science.
And he proved that glyphosate.
And what's happening now with the gut
health,
gut health is such a huge issue.
Everything,
the bad fucking disease,
it starts in the gut and the glyphosate
is eating through the stomach wall and
causing leaky gut and all these other
physical diseases from happening.
Now,
the other thing is you have to realize
what these pesticides are.
They're neurotoxins and then the ones
that they're putting inside the seed.
When the bug eats the leaf,
it fucking dies.
So you're eating these fruits and
vegetables that are completely fucking
toxic.
Well,
here's what happens.
When they created it,
one of the things,
one of the reasons why they were able to
implement it,
they said it doesn't kill people.
It kills plants and it kills bacteria.
So everybody's like,
oh,
fine.
Yeah,
no problem.
It only kills plants and bacteria that's
totally safe.
Know your body is filled with bacteria
or your good bacteria,
the gut as more eco live than there's
ever been a human being on the planet
ever.
There's more cola in your staff and any
humans that have ever lived more numbers
and you need them and need to.
The bacterial flora gets destroyed by
glyphosate gets destroyed by.
That's uh,
that's,
that's.
I mean that podcast that he did that
episode with Dr Zach Bush is fucking.
It's fucking unbelievable and I'm
surprised like,
you know,
motherfuckers didn't try to take
tattooed out at this point.
Well,
it's,
they're making so much money and people
aren't listening and there's so much
signal.
There's so many noises and they use the
word that everyone loves to use.
The two words.
Conspiracy theories.
Yeah.
That's a good one.
But here's the thing.
Once you can prove something in this
data and evidence to back it up,
it's no longer a theory.
It's a fucking fact.
So there's been a conspiracy.
It's just it.
And by the way,
when they implemented it,
they probably did think that they could
get away with it.
They think it would have been fine.
They really probably didn't know as much
as we know today about gut biome.
That's all new shit.
That's all within the last couple of
decades was already tree.
Yeah.
Kimchi is fucking amazing.
I drink a lot of water.
Yeah.
I drink a lot of Kombucha.
Eat a lot of Kimchi.
That's where I get it from primarily.
Yeah.
Good.
That's good stuff.
Yeah,
I mean gut biome is gigantic,
you know,
to the point where people make memes
joking around about me saying gut biome
because I say it so much
and,
and you know,
the other reason that I was,
I didn't know where this whole
conversation would go because I have
respect for you as a martial artist.
Like I said,
I know Brian since the eighties and you
know,
he always talked about you,
but rich roll wrote you and said that I
was up at his house and heard that I was
coming on the podcast and you responded
to him in a text message and said,
yeah,
it's so fucking toxic.
What's going on?
Like,
I just want to sit down.
Yeah.
It's another form of identity politics,
you know,
and people,
look,
there's a lot of people that I'm friends
with that have all sorts of dis.
Uh,
they agree with things that I don't
agree with.
They have ideas that I don't agree with.
I mean,
you're allowed to have varying opinions.
That's what human beings,
we're all about.
We're supposed to be able to communicate
our ideas,
but you're not my enemy.
If you eat plants,
that's crazy.
Right?
And the problem is I eat plants too.
I eat a shitload of them.
Like this idea that you know,
that vegans and mediators are supposed
to be enemies.
I mean,
I had a strange man.
I'm going to tell you straight up,
I hang out with dudes.
Dad fucking eat McDonald's.
Like I have friends.
Like I don't look like I said I'm not
the fly looking for the shit,
you know,
I try to look to the positivity of every
human being and some of them eat meat.
My brother fucking my,
my brother eats meat.
I'm supposed to hate my brother because
my brother eats,
eats fucking meat,
you know it,
it's,
it's just like,
it's like you said,
it's identity politics and I don't roll
with that because if in my line of work
and what I'm doing,
which is getting people out of some
really dark fucking shit in their lives,
like this documentary I'm doing now
called 30 to life to shit that these
fucking inmates have been through.
And the,
you know,
I'm,
I met one guy,
he did 50 fucking years man.
And he's 90 years old and his story is,
he's in amity foundation and it's out
now.
He's in this.
He just got paroled after 50 years,
90 years ago in my fucking phone.
And listen to his story before you judge
a motherfucker cause they got locked up.
He served in World War II in the army.
He served in Korea,
in the army.
He had his friends fucking blown up in
front of him.
Fucking do.
He's seen shit we can't even imagine in
two wars,
Korea.
You know what?
Then motherfuckers went through over
there with the cold and fucking,
I couldn't even bury the bodies brode it
had the fucking stack them with just
insane.
And,
and he came back and went onto the
streets with ptsd.
They didn't even know what the fuck ptsd
was back then when he was going through
it and some shit happened,
which I did not.
He got double life.
So obviously something really bad
happened and I don't know the
circumstances,
but he's 90 fucking years old right now.
And he survived the,
the riots and folsom.
He survived insane fucking shit.
And I'm like Yo.
And he's out now,
he's out now.
He's nine.
There's a fucking picture of him.
A picture of what is it,
what is it like when,
when you're out after fucking 50 years.
And he's the most humble,
genuine fucking dude.
All of these guys like I just got what
we're training to do.
A five k enrich role is leading the run.
And uh,
and I just got Nike to fucking give them
all a air pegasus,
new fucking sneakers skies every fucking
tears.
They're like,
nobody gave a fuck when we first went in
there and met these brothers,
one of the,
one of the biggest Tuv this scariest
motherfuckers broke down in fucking
tears.
And was I gail?
Nobody gave a fuck about me man.
The fact that you guys are coming in
here and doing this for us,
you don't,
you don't know how much this means to
me.
And I mean he had to leave the room.
He was crying.
He,
I'm going to show you the picture of
this cat it.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's why I do here.
This is him right here.
Read that text.
Wow.
Look at them there.
Man.
That's crazy and he's trying to hit on
all the female camera girls like he's a
fucking Papi Chulo I nicknamed or I lost
it.
Sorry.
Just disappeared on me.
Yeah,
right here.
Wow.
Yeah.
He served in both was honorably a ptsd
and I think,
you know,
he said people fuck with him on the
streets.
So what is he,
what is he doing with his life now?
He's in this program.
So they get parole to this program
called Amity Foundation and they serve
out their sentence and try to
reintegrate them.
So what I did was
when I pitched it and it's kept who did
what to health and in cowspiracy and
whatever,
and I,
I hooked up with Paul de gelder.
I don't know if you know him.
He's the Australian navy seal guy.
Lost his arm and leg to the bull shark.
Oh,
we were talking about him yesterday that
mother had carbon fiber is dude.
He's one of the baddest motherfucking,
most positive people you'll ever meet.
His fucking stories.
Insane.
I just read crazy easy seeing him walk
around with that fake arm if they can,
like it's totally normal.
Gave me a fucking,
like I was sitting in the chair and he
came up and was like,
I heard like the hand and I'm like,
no,
fucking.
He almost ripped my fucking shoulder.
Our hand strong dude is fucking.
He's like,
hey,
areas.
Wow.
You know,
I had to be really careful because,
you know,
I used to take care of my business with
the right hand and then like,
that's so crazy man.
Yeah,
dude,
hit a bull shark,
took his arm and leg and now he's on the
discovery channel shark week and he
fights for ocean conservation because if
you kill the lead Predator in the oceans
and the calling that's going on.
So I,
I,
I contacted him and I go,
Paul,
I'm going to tell you right now the
whole Vegan shit is becoming this shit
for rich fucking people.
And the people that really need it are
the ones they can't afford.
Twenty $5 to go to a vege fest and all
this shit.
It's becoming this pompous fucking shit
and the food and you go to try to have a
fucking meal and it's like fucking 50
bucks.
And just in fucking appetizers and the
people that really needed a not getting
access to this.
And I saw 13th,
the documentary about the prison
industrial complex in America,
you know,
you see that.
So you know what's going on.
And I was,
it's prison is basically
slave
slavery.
It did,
is it,
there's a loophole in the law that if
you're incarcerated and do a crime that
you can be put to work and not get paid.
If you get a dollar they're in.
They're making Victoria secret fucking
underwear and all this other shit.
It's fucking crazy.
So it really fucking lit a fire under my
ass.
And I said,
Paul,
I said all this.
A lot of these documentaries are like,
you know,
I eat Vegan and I got big muscles and
fucking whatever the fuck.
I'm like,
what about the motherfuckers that really
needed?
What did I go through?
I've been to fucking hell as a kid.
I was on the streets in New York.
I went to.
I was in the same place.
Mike Tyson was profit in the bronx.
Only white dude in the whole fucking
place.
Fucking went upstate.
Did all this shit.
I'm like,
what changed me,
man?
It was this process.
I said,
the people that need this shit,
they're not getting access to it.
I said,
let's come up with something and fucking
help these people.
Let's go fucking help these dudes who
were coming out of prison.
And then we contacted kip.
He's like,
I want to direct it to me and me and
Paul wrote up the whole treatment and
uh,
and then they contacted.
We were going to try to put him in an
Arabic.
These dudes in a house.
And then we found that the producer
found Elizabeth,
who's the producer,
African-american Chick.
These girls are fucking their money man.
They're fucking great.
Dawn.
And they found this place called Amany
Foundation.
And they're like,
they're already doing this.
They,
they have him in here.
They're doing meditation drum circles,
American Indian chance.
When you were young and your life is
filled,
the turmoil and chaos,
you found the hard as you found this
discipline and becoming a monk and stick
into this plant base training guy,
but you had a be.
It became your ideology became your
life.
If we came like a path and this will,
a lot of people need,
they need a path.
It gives them a feeling of purpose.
It gives them an identity and an
and to made to feel like they matter and
that's what
these motherfuckers that they don't
matter and they even punish you after
you do your time.
That's why they're trying to do.
They're trying to sign this legislature.
That's a do away with the box.
I don't know if you heard about that in
California,
you have to check off a box that you've
been convicted of a crime,
so they're trying to do away with that
because you did your time,
you served your fucking,
you served your time,
you,
you know,
you served your debt to society.
Why should you continue to be fucking
punished and they can't even get a job
working anywhere because no one will
fucking hire them.
So it's a whole.
So what we're doing is I have Dante Ross
coming in.
He's,
you know,
ben in the hip hop game forever.
One of the dudes wants to be a rapper.
Another dude wants to play guitar.
I just hooked up with Yamaha.
They're going to give them good a guitar
amp.
All these shit.
Tal Ronen who owns crossroads
restaurant,
which I heard you talking about,
you.
I listened to your park hdl.
You talking about,
you were talking about,
uh,
that's Travis Barker is he's an
investor.
Yeah.
So Travis.
But Tal Ronen is the chef that runs it.
It's supposed to be amazing dude.
Fucking towel said.
Tell him to come in fucking have a
fucking dinner.
They do fucking everything man.
Crazy food.
He's like,
he's Oprah's chef dude.
And he cooked for the Dalai Lama.
He's like looking kind of thick.
Yeah.
I don't know what she be plant based or
whatever.
The player base some of the time,
snickers bar son.
Oh,
who knows?
Who knows?
But it was about giving these guys
facility to change their lives.
And that's what this documentary 30 life
it is because like,
well they told me,
go out on this 12 for 30 days,
you're going to change your
motherfucking life.
And that's what I did.
And I stuck with it.
And you know,
the training and in everything that I do
for Ironman and you know,
just I'm on my fucking 11th ironman.
Uh,
I'm on the road constantly with the CRO
mags touring A.
I'm in the gym every day.
I'm not trying to be a fucking,
you know,
90 pound fucking iron man,
dude.
I still hit the weights,
hit the bags,
do whatever.
I'm all about recovery now.
Uh,
my friend Aaron J,
a drug,
a zoo ski runs recovery in New York
City.
So I'm all about the see Vac pod and the
new calm,
which provides a,
in 30 minutes you get three hours of
restorative sleep.
His whole shit,
dude.
It's fucking amazing,
man.
I went up there.
I'm like,
it's fucking Guinea pig.
Like all the shit that he's learning,
massage school,
fucking trigger point therapy,
everything that he's been learning.
And he's a bad motherfucker.
He fought in the golden gloves.
He has black belts.
He's a hardcore dude all tatted up and
you know,
I just been on this and I went into
crunch because they were offering a
special thing and he was,
he,
he led the boxing and he taught
kickboxing and worked with all the five
points.
Guys would all be in,
you know,
five points more Thai.
So yeah,
before that,
uh,
they were all up in crunch,
you know,
training and then they opened up the
school,
but he was there and I said,
Yo,
I want to do this ironman.
He started training me from day one to
do my first race.
I started with him and in 2010 I did my
first race,
2012 New York,
New York iron man.
So then his whole journey,
now they open up this place recoveries
right up the block from Hansel Gracie's
on,
on 30th street.
So they have to see Vac pod which takes
you to elevation and increases your vo
two Max by like five point eight
percent.
And I think doping doing the EPO and
everything only gives you three percent.
And then he does the Neukom.
So now I tried to test the shit and I'm
like,
alright,
Neukom it fucking works with the wiring
in your brain.
So you put this,
these fucking,
you put blinders on and you sit there
with these fucking headphones and he has
electrodes.
He puts this gel by the way.
I have his card and he said,
you come to New York next time for
lunch,
right?
Yeah.
So the thing was I tried to fight it and
be like,
no,
I'm fucking not going to pay.
I'm not going to go out.
And the vibrations that they designed
that,
the sound vibration that's coming
through these headphones,
like I'm,
I'm just trying to fight passing out.
And I just fucking went out and then
they woke me up and they're like,
Yo,
how long do you think you were out?
I said,
15 minutes.
They were like,
you out for an hour and 20.
I'm like,
what?
And it's just,
it's fucking bizarre.
Like they're learning so much about
recovery.
And now all this,
uh,
all kinds of pro athletes are coming
into recovery in New York.
Uh,
the,
the studio over there on 30th street all
handles guys handles a nephew who just
won.
What did he just,
what was that?
A MMA tournament.
He just won something.
Fuck it.
He had some fight and he won in.
A lot of those guys are coming in and a
lot of pro athletes,
there's a lot of endurance athletes
that's a go at that are going in.
How does it work?
Then?
There's electrodes that are on,
he puts like,
do you have a tens machine,
you know,
a day.
The gluey fucking pads,
right?
So it's the squares and then he puts
this gel and he puts it behind
productive gel and he puts it behind
your ear here.
And then the headphones and the
blinders.
But it's sending a pulse into your body
and the sound vibrations at attached to
a big machine.
It's a,
it's a fucking little machine like this.
So it's something that we could have
here.
You can,
yeah,
you can have it.
I'm telling you,
man,
you will bug the fuck out.
That sounds crazy.
Like he's an expert in it.
Like the guy who manages the whole shit.
He's an expert in the new comp stuff,
so,
so like,
you know,
he's a big fan of yours by the way too.
He got out to Aaron.
So this is it right here.
Oh,
so when you put this on,
is it on a timer like it's over when
it's over?
No,
they had to wake me up,
man.
That's a those pads.
They woke me to fuck up.
I thought I was out for like 15 minutes.
Step two microcurrent stimulation.
Step two for newcomb is to.
Is to use a sub sensory microcurrent to
catalyze the effectiveness of the new
comp supplementation.
So you take pills with it to know I
didn't take any pills.
I just.
The combination of the supplementation,
the micro current works on the midbrain
to interrupt the body's natural sleep
stress.
Natural stress response.
Research shows this microcurrent helps
balance the brain's neurochemistry by
reestablishing optimal neurotransmitter
levels.
You won't feel it in Swahili as far as
that should help.
The way your brain works.
It's,
it's insane dude.
And and they're the only,
like the only ones in New York that are
doing a new calm.
They're the only ones
in the east coast that have a fucking
evac pod.
One of the universities out here,
they've got one in Orange County.
Ian Mccall was using that shift for
awhile.
He said great,
but the woman who holds the world record
time trial,
I believe she was doing see vac the pod.
It's fucking insane.
You go in this thing and it's like,
uh,
you,
you go,
you have to work up because you can't
just go to level five and,
and you,
you,
you fucking shit.
We'll just bug the fuck out.
So I worked all the way up to level
five.
But how long did it take you to work up
to?
It took me like a couple of weeks,
you know,
but like what I really noticed was with
my running because I mark my threshold
and everything,
so every run when I was training for the
last race,
I just,
I just did Chattanooga a half ironman.
So every run I was doing it's going in
the back and then go in and do the new
calm.
And then I do the normatec boots.
Like they have everything at this place
recover,
so like they're just using and then they
have this other fucking magnetic blanket
that fucking you,
you sit on it and then his isolation pad
on top and it sends these frequencies
through your body.
Oh,
I've done that wasn't mean,
what does that call fucking I'm spacing
on the cryo place and they're getting,
they got cryo coming down and,
and,
and it just flushed like I've noticed
that I can go fucking hardest.
I mean I would have to bike 120 miles
and do a brick and get off the bike and
go run 13 miles and I'm like fucking
breaking threshold fucking records
because I started taking up any athlete
who's serious about even handles,
I think it was his nephew is something
that just had that fight.
The coach was like,
you know,
what the fuck are you doing?
And he's coming into the evac twice,
three times a day.
And he's like,
dude,
he's,
he,
he his gas tank.
He just doesn't run out.
And he's just,
he's fucking grappling.
He's doing everything and he's never
fucking tired.
He's,
I've never seen him perform at this
level.
So the success is there.
Even this woman,
she broke the world record,
I think it was for tt time trial or
track or road or something.
This woman's cycle is,
did see vac and she and they accused her
of fucking doping.
That's at the banner.
Yammer.
Physical fucking legit.
They have that there too.
It does something.
It does something because,
uh,
I've been,
you know,
you're always getting hurt,
you know that too.
I'm always dealing with a fucking
nagging fucking injury.
You got something now like a growing
issue?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
you know,
um,
the,
I've never had a race.
I,
I've got my,
I got my nose broken Cabo ironman.
I'm swimming out in shark infested
waters.
Fucking leaking.
But even from boxing I knew,
don't blow your nose because your eyes
are going to swell shut.
So I had to do all mouth.
We,
I've,
my first ironman I ever did was New York
City and a chromosome.
The drama mackey book,
the fucking show.
This is hardcore,
uh,
the night before.
So we play to like 3000 motherfuckers
going off.
You know that whole mosh and shit and we
fucking lay it down and I fucking had my
brother come down.
He drove me back to New York City.
I had a stress fracture in my foot.
I took a shower and I went to the swim
start and I did an ironman in August
twelfth,
2012 in fucking 95 degrees,
New York city humidity.
But I was not going to be an extra in
your foot.
Stress fracture in my fucking foot.
And the thing is right where the cleat
is.
That's where it pressed.
That's where my stress fracture,
the second metatarsal.
And it was just.
And I didn't take aspirin.
I didn't take nothing.
I'm just like,
you know,
videos like David Goggins volcano,
that fucking maniac.
I'm like,
fuck my pain,
you know,
it took me 13 hours.
And how long did it take you to get over
the stress?
It took months.
And that's why I started wearing hocus.
Now I run with Hoka,
Hoka Hoka these shoes and there's other
big patents.
So that's like a two inch pad.
What is the day your shoe goes down in
there?
It's not actually,
but it's this scientifically designed
foam that absorbs shock from the,
from the road.
So,
um,
a lot of the top heather Jackson runs in
him.
She just fucking has been winning like
crazy.
She was just so fucking better
Christian,
a better cushion and when you get,
you know,
I'm 56 so it's like I'm not a fucking
dude that's recovering so quick as I
used to in my twenties or whatever.
So I might fuck with barefoot running
shoes.
I can't,
man.
It's,
there's no,
there's no cushioning.
I just can't do it.
But you're running.
Do you do a lot of your run on some may
need some time in New York.
I live in New York City.
I might run the trail,
uh,
the bridle trail in central park if I
can or run around the reservoir.
But mostly my shit is all in the city
and the hope is just fucking like,
you know,
I'll be the next day.
People say to me,
Yo,
you must be fucked up for a week after
the race.
I was like,
I did Conan world championships two
years in a row and the first year I did
it 2016,
I fucking went snorkeling with my girl
the next day for like three hours.
So like the inflammation's not there.
I'm getting really dialed in on the
equipment aspect,
getting fitted for the bike,
getting the right shoes to run in it.
It literally took me six years to get
dialed in on,
on even the nutrition aspect and doing
them racist because you don't want to
get a belly full of fucking gels and all
this other shit,
you know,
so anyway,
but the recovery aspect of,
of what I do,
like I just watched,
um,
coggins was on the rich roll podcast and
he was talking about how much yoga and
stretching that he's doing now.
Two,
three,
four hours of fucking street.
And I know you're into yoga lover.
Yeah,
it's fucking great.
And that's what I need to start getting
back into my girl.
Erica is always pushing me.
She's like fucking bought me,
uh,
a,
a kiosk thing for fucking integral yoga.
And she bought that shift for me last
year.
I still,
you know,
it's,
it's what you resist.
Like if you read,
have you read the war of art by Steven?
I fucking love it.
You have in mind,
I bought a stack of his books.
I used to give them out to my guests
don't take
things that are
the war of art,
do the work.
But he talked about resistance and the
main thing about resistance is usually
we're the most resistant to things we
need the most.
Yes.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's this deep shit.
That book I was grateful every morning I
sit down to write my screenplay or my
next book,
I read his shit,
you know,
because it's just.
And the four agreements,
I'm big into two.
I went to actually somebody got me
tickets to see a Miguel speak,
Don Miguel,
and it was a life changing encounter for
me.
The four agreements,
don't take things personal,
always do your best,
be impeccable with your word and don't
make assumptions.
Which I always thought I've created wars
in my fucking mind.
And then they're like,
dude,
I wasn't even taking that.
What the fuck is your problem?
That's classic fucking Dude,
that shit is fucking crazy man.
And I think if everybody just slowed
down and read some literature on some of
these teachers that
humanity could do so,
so much
better.
I agree.
Pressfield's great man,
and what he does say about resistance is
so,
so powerful because there there is
something that keeps you from doing
things that you know you're supposed to
do and when you do them,
you feel so much better.
It's like,
why didn't I just do it?
Why did it?
What was all this procrastination and
bullshit that was involved in me?
Like putting this off and then when you
finally do,
every time I walk out of a yoga class,
I'm like,
I gotta do that again tomorrow.
I got to keep this ball rolling.
This is a part of my life.
I got to go.
Especially for a guy like you because
everything is tight,
Nino's racing and running and
everything,
and then when you're on stage,
everything is crushed,
crushed,
destroyed.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's like the thing about yoga is that
static,
these poses and stretches and your core
gets activated and everything gets
lengthened.
It's just smart way to make it.
Well,
you know what it is.
I try to justify it by going,
well,
I do yoga at the gym when you know,
because I'll do my trigger point and
then I do all my trigger point,
myofascial release,
all that,
and then last 15 minutes my girls like
that shit don't count.
Then it's better than nothing.
You need to.
No,
but I remember how I used to feel when I
would come out of those yoga classes in
81 and I,
I would feel like I could jump over a
fucking building and I need need.
I need to get back to that.
But even in the resistance aspect,
what not doing what you resistant and it
could be something like,
oh,
I made an agreement with myself to
fucking straighten out the papers on my
desk and go to all this shit and if I
don't do it,
it puts me in the worst fucking mood.
Sure.
Because that's what resistance.
When you cave in and you give into
resistance,
man,
it's like you and it could be the
smallest little little thing like you
know,
anything.
Yeah.
And it just,
it just irks the fuck out of you.
I'm like,
Yo.
So I try to.
That's a good philosophy to live by and
you know,
to have something that's been fucking
with you.
Some things you're putting off,
whether it's getting back into yoga or
cleaning up your daughter to quitting
smoking or whatever it is.
Having that thing over your head where
you know,
you haven't taken care of,
it makes you think less of yourself and
make yourself less.
Yeah.
And,
and that's one of the things I tell
these,
everybody I work with because I mean
literally today and I'm not bullshitting
on unsure,
I don't try to be like,
you know,
I don't even say I'm some kind of
teacher.
Whatever.
I just pass the info to these
motherfuckers.
I today I had fucking four people come
up to me on the street.
Yo,
I heard you on rich.
Well fucking so you want to love what
you doing man?
You fucking help me.
I got into triathlon now,
I quit fucking drugs.
This guy told me that today,
and he's like,
Yo,
I quit drugs.
I fucking stopped drinking that.
That's what it's all about.
That is what am I going to give a fuck
them be like zone in on something and
find fault with what the fuck he's
doing.
I was like,
Yo man,
props to you dude.
Fucking,
you know,
you could do anything you know,
you apply yourself to.
And nance really,
you know,
um,
my whole thing in life is to just,
you know,
and that's what part did proper.
Came to America in his seventies of
border geology to cross two oceans,
had two heart attacks almost passed
away.
But his teacher in India said to go to
America at 70 years old with $7 in a
case of bog of toms.
And he came to America to the lower east
side to the bowery.
What's a burger with Tom?
The Bagua.
Tom Srimad.
Bhagavatam is what's known as the
spotless Parana.
It's a,
the bog of a time she went back to the
time is an ancient literature in India.
It's called.
It's part of the Puranas is called the
spotless Paranas,
so there's 10 days of the book,
10 candles he didn't even have.
He brought the original texts that have
been passed down from one teacher to the
next to the next,
to the next in India,
and they said his teacher
Bhaktisiddhanta said,
you need to write these books in English
for the world to help the world,
so he didn't owe the people in India
with like Swamiji,
you know you are.
You're at the end of your life.
Why are you going to go to America?
It's a very dangerous place,
not only to go to America.
He went to fucking New York to the
bowery.
They robbed him.
He slept on the floor.
He Fed people.
He cooked me.
Alan Ginsburg Academy's first storefront
over there called matches gifts,
and they saw the humility of this person
probably pod and what he did for people.
How he has so much love.
He would cook the meals,
serve everybody clean up before you
would even eat a grain and rice.
He had no possessions,
none.
He slept on the floor on a mat and they
saw the humility of him and he just.
And when I learned this story,
there's a great documentary on him
called you're ever well wisher on
youtube and it's about his life and how
he came and you know,
uh,
Charya means one who leads by example.
It's not what,
and I've learned this just by these big
mounds that are out there that talked so
much shit.
It ain't,
what the fuck you say,
it's what you do.
It's about your action and your words
and how you interact with other people
and how you see other people,
even these fucking so-called celebrities
is when the camera's ain't on.
How do you treat people,
you know,
what the fuck is the real core of your
existence?
What are you here to do?
And when I saw a proud part and,
and,
um,
you know,
read all this stuff on him and then
started taking up the process,
I was like,
you know,
um,
it just changed,
changed my life so that you know,
for the better so
well by you saying that.
And it was very enticing for people,
right?
Like the guy I want to do what he's
doing,
I wanna I want to feel better,
like he's feeling better.
That's what's amazing about having
someone who's a great role model,
meaning like me.
You might not even think of yourself as
a role model,
but by living your life by example,
by doing things that you should do,
but being healthy by being active and
enthusiastic,
but you've got passionate about what
you're doing about your music,
about pushing yourself,
about your books,
about the exercise.
And when you do that,
people that don't have purpose in their
life,
they see that and they go,
that's what I'm missing.
I'm missing because we're missing so
many things in this life.
But one of the things that people are
missing is role models.
They're missing someone who they can
look up to and go,
oh,
I.
This is the way to do it.
And it.
And when you emulate their lifestyle and
start thinking the way they think and
using their lessons and applying them to
your own life,
you start seeing benefits and then that
passes down to other people who see you.
It's like a candle.
One candle can light up.
Like hr was that for me,
like her could have been telling me to
worship fucking cheetos and and I would
have done it.
Thankfully he was into the right shit.
But I would see him go on stage and I
would see his humility.
He wouldn't.
He would always say,
John is the ability of anything that I
have.
He would always give praises to the most
high to John.
Rastafari humble is fucking hell.
And the best musicians to ever.
Those four motherfuckers are praise by
every single fucking musician today.
If you talk Doc Daryl,
earl and Gary doctor know every
motherfucker musician out there,
it will be like,
those dudes are fucking Don's because
they study music.
They were into jazz and they were into
fucking return to forever.
And John Mclaughlin,
Mahavishnu dark in 81 was like,
they call me squids because they met me
in an Aeo squids.
I'm going to take it to the palladium
return to forever because they met me in
the navy.
Oh,
squid,
squid.
Squid.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
and then they call me Johnny Joe.
So that's where the John Joseph,
I didn't use my last name.
[inaudible].
I was fucking a future there for 15
years.
Oh,
that's funny.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
the,
the thing was,
he's returned to forever as al Di Meola,
Lenny White Stanley Clarke.
And I'm missing chickarina fucking do
you ever listen to this shit?
So you want to go down a motherfucking
know,
listened to return to forever romantic
word.
You want to go down a rabbit hole with
how fucking amazing these fucking
musicians are,
or weather report or any of these,
you know,
Maha Vishnu,
birds of fire.
Like they started turning me and he
would say,
squids,
this is how we learn to play with the
fuck we play.
And nobody could touch the bad brains
musically.
Energy on stage.
Nothing.
And I would see these dudes.
I'd be like,
what the fuck are you into?
And then the role models that,
like you said it,
you know,
we need good role models.
There's,
you know,
there's so many fucked up people that
these kids want to emulate today.
You know,
and I see it because I came up in New
York,
I worked in all the underground hip hop
clubs.
I work for the Pope or pot.
I used to deliver pot to all the rap
stars.
I delivered pot pot.
My friend,
uh,
the student Matt worked for Tristar.
You like,
Yo meet me at the Boston Comedy Club.
There's this black comedian there and
he's gonna be fucking huge.
And I would show up on my bike and you
know who you know,
who the fuck it was?
Dave Chappelle,
Chappelle,
they fucking Chappelle.
And when he did half baked,
did you notice that he put the weed
delivery guy in all bike here?
Where the fuck he think he got that
phone?
I used to show up.
I never carried a bag.
I showed up with a $4,000 carbon fiber
carbon fiber frame and I had a black
water bottle.
And all the weed bags was in the two
water bottles.
So it just looked like I was a cyclist
out on a motherfucking out on a ride.
Oh,
Dave Chappelle.
Yeah.
And then they,
uh,
Dave Chappelle,
we didn't,
he,
he blew up so fast.
Matt Heine was the guy's name.
He was the publicist at Tristar pitches
and then I delivered to them at the
Boston comedy club and within like
months he was living in some police show
fucking spot on second avenue and 15th
in the.
And I'm like,
Yo,
how the fuck did you get from their
head?
He just,
you know.
But yeah,
it's like,
um,
you know,
just thankfully the dudes show me the
right path in life.
And uh,
I've been,
I've been trying to stick with it and
pay it forward.
That's my whole thing is paying it
forward,
paying the knowledge forward pain.
You go out of my way to fucking help
people.
I feed the homeless in New York.
I sponsor a soup kitchen.
I've done benefits that have been on MTV
because you know,
I grew up being starved,
man in the foster home,
like this bitch fed us.
She would take a oreos and she didn't
like to fill in,
so she would scrape off the filling and
spit it in a bowl and put it on green,
moldy bread.
That was our meal for the day.
So we had to learn to scam as kids.
They fed us rotten food.
We were never allowed in the house.
They beat the shit out of us.
They were so cheap.
They made us clean their carpets with
toilet bowl brushes,
new toilet bowl brush,
because they didn't want to run the
electricity.
All seven kids had to take a bath in the
same fucking bathtub water,
one after the other.
So how do we get around that?
We went to the fucking gas station and
we would fucking bathe,
do pocket showers and everything was
about survival.
It was all survival,
survival.
Even even on the streets.
I was a heroin mule.
That's how I survived.
I,
I left St John's.
That's how I got into punk rock.
You know,
the Ramones,
rock,
rock away,
beach St John's home for boys,
rockaway beach,
1976.
I'm like,
Yo,
I'm weird.
And I started getting into iggy pop and
all that and then,
you know,
it was,
and then I'm seeing the ramones hanging
out at 116th street at the circle.
And um,
and when I split from the boys home,
I moved in with these junkies in this
bungalow and they're like,
Yo,
go down the alphabet city,
you're gonna,
you're gonna.
Carry all the heroin back for us.
So that was my gig and then he set the
guy up and robbed him and all this crazy
shit.
Then I was making fake acid and go into
the garden and it just a fucking street
urchin.
And then I got into the angel dust,
a selling it in forest park at the dome.
Frank Grillo.
His father knew who,
you know,
Frank Grillo to actor.
Yeah.
He's friends with talent.
Very good friends.
Fucking,
he's another great human being man.
Uh,
frank.
I know from crunch I met him at crunch
actually,
like there was a lot of cool people that
were in his father.
He goes,
Yo,
I just read this guy's book,
like you hung out.
His father was like supposedly homeless
and flaws.
You remember this kid that used to hang
out with disco and oldies and Bobby Byrd
and all these guys.
And so he's like,
Yo,
where the fuck did you hear those names?
Like is this Guy John,
you know,
John Joseph v was a fucking kid back
then.
And,
and uh,
you know,
it was,
was on the streets over there and
fucking selling,
selling dust at the dome.
And uh,
so just all,
you know,
all that crazy.
Like I've been around all those negative
people and try to like,
you know,
I had people,
this one guy,
junior nuts and ducky host and they both
got murdered,
but they will be like,
take that pipe and go smash that guy in
the fucking face with it.
And I would do it because I was 14 years
old.
I'm on the fucking streets and you know,
you try to impress crazy motherfuckers
by being crazy and I did a lot of fucked
up stupid shit in my life.
Then I'm still trying to write a,
the karmic scales for.
So my work will never be done until the
last breath I take in,
in his lifetime.
I,
I'm trying to help trying to help
people.
And uh,
you know what,
by whatever methods I can,
you know,
that's what.
Well,
that's a beautiful path,
man.
I mean,
you've turned a terrible situation and a
terrible,
terrible circumstances into a way that
you've created now where you're
inspiring people all the time.
That's very positive.
I mean,
just the impact that you have.
I think one of the things that we were
talking about earlier about all the
negativity that people have online.
I think part of the problem with that is
I don't think people totally understand
communication.
I think what we're handed is these tools
to distribute our thoughts and our
information and we're trying to get
rudimentary reactions and we're not
understanding that these reactions don't
just stop with the person that we're
interacting with.
They affect ourselves because they
affect how we feel about ourselves.
If you write some petty shit about
someone you don't respect yourself,
you,
you.
If you write some nasty,
snarky,
petty shit about someone and you're
insulting for no reason,
you know you're insulting for no reason
and you feel it yourself.
You don't have great self respect for
yourself for that,
and then on top of that,
that person that you hurt their
feelings,
they might perhaps interact with other
people negatively because of that as
well.
Chain reaction they might get.
They might become the first to attack
next because they'd been attacked before
too,
so they start acting that way in the for
what it is is a lack of understanding
that a lot of us have,
all of us,
I've been guilty of it to have the
impact that our,
that our communication has because we're
not thinking about it in a comprehensive
widescale look with thinking about in
terms of that is annoying to me,
so I'm going to fuck that guy's world up
by saying shitty things about him and
his fat,
stupid face and whatever you want to say
about them.
And insult them,
and
I'm going to tell you what a lot of the
problem is too.
And I see it all the time.
We're losing the art of even having a
conversation between human beings
because this is what everybody does when
you see them going down the
motherfucking street and Yo New York is
still motherfucker's dangerous.
And now all these motherfucking texting
zombies can come out of the club and
they fucking
rob.
They're getting run over there getting
fucking crazy,
you know.
But the thing is,
is like this right now,
we have a law.
I go out with my friend Jake from rocks
off in New York City.
He does all the rocks off towards it,
does all this stuff.
He has a role.
When he out to dinner,
everyone has to hand them motherfuckers
cell phone in to the fucking Maitre d
and no cell phones.
So that you sit there and talk with each
other.
You have the conversation and it's,
what is it?
You know,
I saw this whole special and it was um,
it was on CNN and it was Anderson
Cooper.
And um,
it was the guy that was teaching
mindfulness,
I forget he's been teaching meditation.
I wrote about him in my book.
So the whole rule was they had to be
mindful the entire time that they were
at this thing.
They had that no cell phone,
no TV,
no nothing.
And they had to be mindful when they ate
mindful,
when they took a shower,
mindful when they walked down the
street,
remaining mindful during conversations,
respecting other people and like it was
heads of the heads,
the CEO of fucking Google and all these
big companies were there and what they
learned at this retreat for the 10 days
or whatever,
that they were there a week.
It was so powerful that they took that
and implemented that in their companies.
And now google,
they make everybody sit down and in
fucking auditorium before they start
their day up there in a silicone valley
or wherever the fuck they are.
And they have to just sit there for 10
minutes and be mindful and meditate and
be mindful.
And that's something that's becoming a
lost part of humanity because it,
you know,
the,
the Internet and all of this shit.
It's like people are losing touch with
themselves and with each other.
You don't validate me.
I don't got to,
you know,
what I do with them.
People when they even knew I was coming
on here and they was talking shit I
fucking deleted.
I didn't even read them off.
Uh,
comments.
Once I saw a few toxic words,
I'm like,
fuck you,
delete block.
See a fucking later.
To me it's out of sight,
out of mind.
I just don't have time for people
capable of.
Yeah.
Because you know,
I still have the tendency to do the for
disagreements.
I,
I do take things personal.
I will make assumptions.
I'm,
I'm a work in progress.
I'm not healed.
Just like I say,
I'm always going to be an addict.
There's always that possibility that I'm
going to fucking.
I have to have my coat of armor,
which I say in my sword of fucking pma
and my coat of armor,
which is everything I do everyday,
but I'm not beyond the shit.
I'm China,
so you know,
why the fuck do I want to go hang out
with very negative people or listen,
you know,
or if somebody starts talking shit about
somebody else,
you know what I say to them now,
Yo my man,
did you tell so and so that,
why the fuck you telling me I don't
want,
I don't want to hear it and I forget
which philosopher said it,
but he goes,
the only true a examination of a,
like when we find fault in others,
it's really what we're seeing in
ourselves.
We're pointing out the bad shit and
ourselves for sure constantly for
finding,
you know,
with other people.
And it comes back to that fly mentality,
man.
I just,
you know,
and try to set the good example and
that's another thing Paul said examples
better than precept and right now you
just have a motherfucker,
a bunch of people talking shit instead
of trying to be the example and try to
live it and do it.
There are a ton of people out there that
is crushing it and staying positive and
doing,
you know,
getting off drugs,
getting off alcohol,
like even the people in this program and
you don't even notice shit that these
guys have been to.
It's fucking insane.
Can you imagine spending 20 years in a
fucking jail cell or going to Pelican
Bay or going at Pelican Bay,
being in the shoe,
like what the fuck that does to human
beings.
Like the strength that that takes,
and I'm going to tell you,
and the other reason I got involved is
because my uncle back in the day worked
at Chino prison in the seventies and
eighties.
He was like the assistant warden or
something in Chino,
Chino,
if you know the prison system,
what they call it here in California is
gladiator school,
but there's a documentary about this guy
and he's a former navy seal and he went
in there and the documentary's called
salvage lives and he went in there and
taught these guys.
He put them through like a little buds.
Dang squirted him with holes,
trained them.
Fucking hot as hell.
Taught him every aspect of commercial
diving and when they got released he got
them jobs on oil rigs and all this
stuff,
making six figures and the guys who were
working for these oil companies,
they said these are the most skilled
fucking people that we've ever had come
to work for these companies.
So between trying to be the set a good
example and seeing that people before me
that's done it and wanting to reach out
and help people have seen and my uncle
telling me about this guy and then
seeing the documentary when it came on,
I was just like,
I gotta try to do something to turn the
tide and having a platform like Netflix
or whoever is going to pick up this
documentary.
It's like,
you know,
if it could show people listening,
stopping costs,
aerating motherfuckers.
It's about education,
not incarceration.
These are not animals.
These are human beings.
It's a broken system.
It is.
Sure.
It's not helping anybody.
It's just making people harder.
Criminals and it's just punishing them
by keeping them locked in a cage and
they never get any better.
And then the idea is that you're
removing the dangerous elements of
society and protecting the rest of us.
Yeah,
I get that.
But there's this idea of rehabilitation.
It's nonexistent
now.
They even removed the exercise equipment
in the prison because now if you watch
13 years,
right?
Yeah,
they,
you know,
it's basically like warehousing bodies,
man and violate them.
One dude got violated for smoking a
cigarette in a facility and they sent
them back to serve the rest of his
fucking sentence.
There is crazy.
And especially out here in California
like California and Texas and Florida,
man is fucking crazy.
You know.
And,
and,
and look,
I look back to the whole situation that
went down in the eighties because I
really try to do research and the whole
thing that went down.
You had a nancy fucking Reagan saying,
just say no.
And you know what George Bush senior was
doing the fondos operations in South
America.
You know about that selling crack.
Fuck is selling motherfucking crack.
The vice president was bringing the
cocaine landed in freeway.
Ricky on Holy Shit landing the planes in
Arkansas.
Right?
But Governor Clinton and transporting
the cocaine and then decided the Tom
Cruise movie.
Fuck yeah,
I saw it.
I loved it.
What is it called?
Made in America.
America made in America.
Yeah.
And the thing was,
and then they passed.
They passed these draconian fucking drug
laws like,
I think you could get caught.
I forget what the exact amount of grams.
We're of minute portion of crack
cocaine.
And there was dudes getting busted with
quarter pounds of Co fucking coke,
but that's white man's.
And they would get fucking a slap on the
wrist.
These dudes will go away for 10 years.
So they,
they put the cocaine in neighborhoods,
they funded all their operations in
South America and then they pass
draconian drug laws.
And this was the Clintons.
Hello,
Michael.
Rupert.
Rupert was exposed all that.
Do you remember they had those town hall
meetings with the Dea and the CIA and
the Michael Rupert who was a,
he was a homicide detective for the Los
Angeles Police Department.
You know what I did?
I did,
I did.
I think
it wasn't a homicide.
It was homicide.
Right.
And he,
um,
he went in front of this big meeting on
CNN and explained it to everyone was
cspan or CNN,
I don't remember,
but it was on television and he
explained that he busted the CIA selling
drugs in the inner city and that he has
documents that can prove there's a
detailed history of them selling drugs
than using those profits overseas.
There was a documentary about it that
came out and it was these big,
uh,
the big drug dudes in La said,
yeah,
these guys would just show up with
fucking van loads of fucking cold.
Can you ever see that video of him
talking in front of those people?
See if you find that video because it's
fucking crazy eyeopening video.
But there's,
they're having this town hall meeting.
Here it is right here.
Oh yeah.
I saw drugs throughout this country for
fuck him.
How been
crazy
allegations of CIA involvement in
it.
They,
they
listened.
I obvious way.
That is an answer for a lot of you.
And now had you played.
I refer now.
Can you place I to right?
Wait,
wait,
what the fuck?
The CIA selling drugs just told
everybody that.
Do you know that they declassified those
papers to fucking those.
You can read all of those papers now
online that they fucking did that shit.
Then they invested in the fucking
prisons.
So they're making money.
That's the crazy thing.
Is privatized prisons
the most evil thing that you can make
money and therefore you're incentivized
to make draw the drug laws are more
strict so you can get more people in
prison.
So you generate more income.
13th man,
if you ain't seen [inaudible]
documentary.
When I saw that,
I knew what my calling was to do because
you know Noah Levine,
he wrote this book,
Dharma punks and he's been a Buddhist.
He was a heroin addict.
He used to do a Buddhist ministry and
the prisons in and change these people's
lives and you know,
he,
they came out in his magazine called
Satya and I read this article.
So Satya in Sanskrit means the motive
goodness.
So that's what this magazine was called.
And I read this article about these
inmates daddy was working with and one
of them said he was never getting out.
He's,
you know,
life without the possibility.
And he said if I had access to the
information of what I've learned through
this program,
I wouldn't be where I'm at.
So then that planted the seed in me and
then just seeing what the whole shit
turned into,
how the people that really need the food
deserts in everything that's going on in
this country and the research I've done
and everything I've been talking about
and fighting for change by taking action
against the fucked up shit.
And then 13th coming out and just lit
another fire under me.
I'm like,
man,
let's fucking like help these people,
man.
And,
and um,
but yeah,
the whole I knew about all that coke
shit back in the fucking day.
And at first I was like,
Yo,
because congress wouldn't cut a check to
him to do his dirty fucking shit down in
South America.
Good.
We got our hands in wars all over this
fucking trying to take down governments
all over this fucking planet,
man.
It's insane.
Yeah.
That barry seal story's fantastic.
That's the guy who they the Tom Cruise
played in that movie.
I mean,
it's a fucked up version of it in the
movie.
I'm sure it's not totally accurate,
but that guy was selling drugs and he
was going to South America and bringing
them over and dropping them off in
Arkansas while Clinton was the governor.
Any part of them.
There's The da do it was like,
I fucking got you.
Yup.
Call comes.
Let them go.
Guess who it was?
Bill Clinton.
Yeah.
That's fast.
That's a fucking fact.
That really happened and you get,
you know
Hillary Clinton,
I'm for black people in this and that.
No you ain't you.
And now she's like,
yeah,
we have to change the fucking prison
laws and the sentencing laws on drugs
though.
You created those two.
Three strikes was your fucking husband.
She's a fascinating character because
people want to think of her as being
this super progressive person because
she's a woman and because she's a
Democrat,
she didn't believe in gay marriage
until 2013.
Sorry,
Shit I got.
I got fucking.
I saw videos of talking shit against gay
marriage and,
and like,
you know,
marriage should be to unity of a man and
a woman and guy like it's all political.
It's all mouthpieces.
They,
they changed it.
No one can take a stance and say,
this is who the fuck I am.
The matter what group I'm talking in
front of that.
So I look to and have respect.
I don't change my stance on shit.
Well,
you remember when Bernie Sanders is
trying to get it to release the
transcripts of those speeches that she
gave in front of the bankers.
Come on,
tell us what you.
Those fucking things buried long gone
like,
no chance.
You're not going to release those.
That would be some dark shit where she's
making sure that you're going to make
more money.
You can me an office.
I'm going to make sure you keep making
money.
We're here to make you make more money.
I,
I've seen,
uh,
your comments on trump to some pong.
What do you think about homeboy
this?
I think no one should be president.
And I think the idea of having a
popularity contest fucking ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
Well,
we should have as a council of wise
people and they should have school,
the real shit be a group of the most
wise a codified yes,
but I mean you should.
Your.
Your work should be judged like it
shouldn't be partisan.
It shouldn't be.
You're trying to appeal to social
justice warriors are radical
progressives or radical conservatives or
right wing Christian fundamentalists.
It should be you're making sense because
you understand law and fairness and
ethics and morals and values and you
understand like with an objective sense
and an educated sense of how to
establish a quality community of human
beings,
civilization in which people can prosper
in which laws are fair and in which we
we established what are what,
what,
what do we find necessary?
What do we find important?
What's imperative?
Education,
community,
all these different values and enforce
those in it somehow or another,
figure out a way to make this world a
better place than what it is now.
Engineer a better place.
That's not what we get.
What you get is some person who says
they're going to do all kinds of shit
until they get in there and they very
rarely do.
Did you see the Ab shit that they just
put up for all of fucking trump,
like the shitty promise on the campaign
and now we're actually doing.
It's fun.
No one's done any different,
but Obama did the same shit.
Bama did the same shit.
They get.
Listen,
Hillary would've done the same shit.
They all,
they all do the same shit.
And,
and the thing that fucked me up the most
is the vote doesn't decide who the fuck
gets in tradition.
It's fucking the electoral college is.
What the fuck is that shit?
Who is that?
Who the fuck?
Wonderful.
The government was a great idea when you
had to get on a fucking horse and take
your ass to Washington in order to place
your votes.
You don't have to do that anymore.
You could vote instantaneously.
People should be able to vote on issues
with their phone.
Okay?
Your phone's in your pocket all the
time.
You should be able to.
First of all,
you should have some sort of
understanding what you're voting on.
You should have to pass some sort of
test.
They should say,
look,
do you want to vote about,
you know,
do you want to vote on spending?
Do you want to vote on healthcare?
How much do you understand about
healthcare?
Well,
let's take a test and the people that
can pass the test,
understanding what the consequences are,
why they're doing this,
then you should be able to vote,
but this should be something that you
should have some skin in the game.
There should be some understanding of
what the system is.
Instead,
you know,
look,
I'm not a giant supporter of any
mainstream media,
whether it's a right wing or left wing,
but there's something fucked up about
these people from CNN go to these trump
rallies and you got hundreds of people
giving them the finger.
Fuck you.
You're fake news.
Fucking they got an American flag tee
shirts on.
It's.
Yeah,
there's,
there's a,
a nonsense almost pro wrestling aspect
to all this.
What has become it,
but he's profiting off this.
Trump is.
This is for his,
his,
his advantage.
He set this up because he found a broken
system and he said,
oh,
I just fucking rigged the system.
I know how to get people to like me.
I've been doing this forever.
I'm a cocky,
arrogant billionaire.
That's my shtick.
I'm going to walk up there with my
$5,000 suit on and I'm going,
wow,
the shit out of these dummies and I'm
going to have cheered for me until these
guys are fake news.
You sit down,
you're fake news,
and everybody goes crazy.
Yeah.
Did you see that somebody just.
His video was,
I think it was.
Might've been seen in and posted and it
was like the toxic level of it was his
group and they were just yelling at Jim
Acosta.
Yeah,
that was talking about that too.
I saw it and they were all like,
fuck you fucking screen.
I'll tell you something because I'm a.
I'm a native New Yorker and I have
friends that are in the unions and they
built fucking trump.
Burned a lot of fucking people and got
rid of fucking skilled labor and skilled
fucking a union people and burned union
people and hired illegals to do the
fucking work and his fucking bill.
All this shit.
This guy says he's,
you know,
everybody says what they have to say in
order to get the votes.
And he didn't have a good reputation
amongst console.
Terrible,
terrible.
So not for paying his bills to,
hey yo.
So many lawsuits against in school that
he fucking trump university,
trump university.
If you gave that motherfucker your
money,
but you know what the doesn't mean that
Hillary would have been a good choice.
Now.
She was a terrible choice.
She's
a corrupt politician.
One of the most unlikable people that's
ever run for office.
She in so many ways,
crazy shit.
We're trying to get it.
They were trying to get people to be
supporting her just because she's a
woman.
There was a lot of that.
It's like,
this is going to be your history.
You know,
women ladies,
I stand with her.
So there's all these women at this
blind,
allegiance towards this career
politician.
It's completely full of shit.
She's been full of shit forever.
If you watched the conversation between
James Komi when James Comey testified
about what he did and what they found
with the Hillary Clinton emails and then
her version of it,
she's just a straight liar.
She deleted 33,000 emails.
Do you do that?
And then,
and then,
uh,
even worse than that,
when they rig the DNC,
they've rigged the primary so that
Bernie Sanders was gonna lose.
They mean they,
she had her people to.
The DNC was an advanced that Donna
Brazil book about his mind.
Yes.
The thing was he was packing fucking
stadium.
She couldn't even fill a fucking
highschool gymnasium.
She was pulling all the strings and she
had all the favors that she was pulling
in and she had a shit ton of money
behind her and they were completely
arrogant and all the liberal elite and
the media thought that it was no chance
she was going to lose.
She's 95 percent shoe in to win the
presidency.
And she walked around like she was.
She thought she won.
But you had to Bengazi Shit.
What the fuck was up with that?
Exactly what the fuck was going on over
there?
That lie and you know,
uh,
with the dirt that's on a,
I hope,
you know,
whatever.
Bill Clinton,
I know you eat vegan sometimes so nobody
had a real problem with it.
When,
when,
when the hate rotten them out
all times he pulled.
But like,
but like she get away with that.
Like what?
Like how about shaming all the women
that came out and accused him.
She would attack those women and go
after them and the,
you know,
they mean bordain talked about that
recently before he killed himself.
There was a thing about what she had
done to attack the women who were
victims of bill,
especially earlier career.
Oh God.
She fucking represented trauma Lester.
So it was one of the things that she did
earlier in her career.
She got them off,
you know,
there's a,
there's a videotape that Dave Smith was,
she was laughing in one of them about
the victims.
Like I'm like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
She was laughing about the effectiveness
of lie detector tests.
And like,
obviously I don't work.
Ha Ha.
Yeah.
She's a piece of work.
She is man.
She's a long time lifelong politician
and a lawyer.
And what's all the shit that went down
in Arkansas?
The shit that the whole day were all
accused of back in the day.
What was that?
The a whitewater.
The Whitewater shit like.
And just the string of people that have
been fucking whack to Vince.
Yo,
what is a great book I read a long time
ago called the strange death of Vince
foster.
It's like,
wait a minute.
What?
They found the gun in his hand,
which you never do when you kill
yourself,
when you shoot yourself,
he pulled that trigger blam.
Everything goes,
the gun goes flying.
You don't hold onto it is recoiling the
gun like you know,
and you blow your brains out.
You're not holding your gun anymore.
It goes flying.
And he was.
He had the gun in his hand and the blood
that was missing from his body was not
on the scene of the crime.
So the researchers think that they moved
his body.
He was dead.
They put them there and make the crime
scene.
They put a gun in his hands up,
case closed.
But what was he testified he was going
and fucking,
he knew he had information about
Whitewater.
I mean,
what he was going to say and who knows
they killed them.
We'll never find out.
How about the guy that,
uh,
was one of the whistleblowers for Enron,
shot himself in the head twice and he
threw that shit sylaria shoot yourself
in the head twice.
Luck.
Case closed.
That's clearly a suicide.
I mean,
I guess you could kind of graze your
head if you pussied out like,
ah.
And he's like,
fuck,
I'm bleeding.
I could do it.
It is possible,
but it's more likely somebody killed.
People kill people.
It's part of the thing when you're
involved with billion dollar deals with
giant corporations and they also tied
into the military industrial complex,
who by the way,
kill innocents all the time and write it
off like all this shit that happened
with drones.
What's the number?
It's like in the high eighties or 90
percent innocent people killed by
drones.
They don't worry about that.
You think they're going to worry about
some guy's gonna sink,
Monsanto,
or sink and faucet or sink the Clintons
or sync.
Anybody?
Fuck that.
Send the boys whacked out,
cleaned it up.
Absolutely chops off the head twice.
This conference.
We're all good.
Everything's wonderful.
Here's Monsanto with some new glyphosate
that's going to fix your corn.
You'll never have to fucking pigweeds,
but I,
I read this thing that most of the,
most of the glyphosate that's being put
out there is by people on their fucking
own homes,
like they don't know any better.
They spray roundup.
It's A.
I have a friend who had bone cancer and
he lived near a golf course and they put
so many pesticides in the golf course
that had got into the groundwater.
Right?
And he said,
all these people in his neighborhood got
cancer and he wound up.
He has a fake femur bone.
One of his femur bones,
a metal.
It's a metal bone.
You got bone cancer.
They cut his bone out and they replaced
it with this metal pipe.
Well,
my uh,
you know,
the,
the history of them two was agent orange
and all this other shit and my uncle was
forced recon in the marines and he got
fucking like everyone in his unit that
got behind fucking enemy lines and airy
got Ms. Cancer,
fucking the shit.
They was spraying that shit on our own
fucking troops.
Yeah.
Well they figured,
look this,
this is the way we got to get with.
The problem is they're hiding in the
jungle.
We got to get rid of the jungle.
It's just killed the jungle with poison,
with this crazy thinking.
They just sprayed chemicals all over the
jungle
to kill the fucking forest so they could
see where the enemy are hardened.
And then they had the troops walking
through those chemicals.
It's fucking nuts.
It is.
History will not judge them kindly when
they step back and think about what they
actually did mean.
It's in the 19 sixties were our parents
generation and the way we look at it as
almost like this unfortunate thing that
happened,
but I almost think we're too close to it
to recognize how horrific it is that the
soldiers who were putting their lives on
the line in their thought to defend our
freedom over in America,
we're getting poisoned by their own
government.
Okay,
good.
Iraq,
where would they put knowledgeable.
Depleted uranium.
Exactly.
These soldiers coming back from the Gulf
War and everything else.
We're dumping all the fucking depleted
uranium over and over there.
It's a dumping ground for us.
They're getting fudges dumping they were
using and we're using it as meant they
were putting it in in they in.
They will weaponizing and and then all
the fucking troops are coming back.
Having fucking kids with deformities and
getting cancer and all this shit turned
down for their benefits.
Yeah,
they denied it was even it fucking.
What the fuck is that
care that it's all about money for them.
They're there.
They're distantly removed from it.
The same way someone's distantly removed
from factory farming.
If they buy a burger at a restaurant or
a burger at a fast food joint,
then not thinking about a pig that's in
that can,
that makes that mcrib they're not
thinking about that.
And the people that connect.
Yeah,
and the people that are thinking about
the numbers on the paper.
Look,
they're number crunchers.
They gotta to save the government some
money,
deny them,
make them fight
for syndrome.
My uncle gave up.
Did you see the attachment?
Speaking of,
uh,
the military industrial complex,
did you see the latest movie that came
out with Woody Harrelson?
Shocking.
Alive.
You seen that?
You know,
I didn't say about how.
Oh,
they uncovered the whole fucking thing
about how the fucking weapons of mass
destruction was just a complete lie.
Every news media outlet except for one
lied and backed up the government's
claim and the whole shit that times all
times ended up apologizing like we got
it wrong.
So you go in there,
you fucking send troops in there,
you fucking kill how many millions of
fucking innocent people over there and
add it to what to sell to sell fucking
weapons.
And,
and push another
in the eye and then there's the
justification after the act.
Well,
hey,
it was a good thing to get Saddam
Hussein there out of there anyway.
He was a bad guy,
but you haven't worked with him in the
early eighties and gave him the fucking
gas that he used.
So what the fuck is like?
You know,
that was just some yeehaw shit.
Fucking homeboy.
No,
well it was,
it was.
They took advantage of an opportunity.
We got attacked,
you know,
September 11th.
The planes get hit by the towers,
got hit by the planes.
Everybody wanted to action and this was
an opportunity for them to take
advantage of this call for action.
And though we're going against someone
that had nothing to do with the attacks
on September 11th,
people felt like something was
happening.
The head guy from,
from,
from a department of defense was like,
well,
what do you mean they're fucking,
you gotta see this movie.
It's all fact based too.
It's like,
what do you mean we're going in Iraq?
Didn't have anything to do with it.
What the fuck are we going into,
IRA?
Oh,
well he,
you know,
and then they tried to say he led a
Osama bin Ladin if the NSF,
if Osama bin Ladin met Saddam was saying
face to face,
he would tell them to go fuck himself.
That's how different ideologies.
Those two hats.
Yeah,
Sama Bin Ladin was religious.
He's.
It's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
they just sold it.
They kept.
But what's great about the movie is it
shows how they just started force
feeding the information out there to
create this fucking feverish,
kill,
kill fucking mentality that the
Americans.
Well,
the same thing.
You're seeing what these people
screaming at Jim Acosta and you can
manipulate dummies mindsets and this is
what they do.
I mean this is an easy way to pull the
strings of the most easily lead.
You got to think who's going to these
rallies in the first place?
Most of these people that are going to
these trump rallies or something like
that,
they're morons.
That's why they're going to these
things.
They don't have shit to do.
Even if you're a trump supporter,
if you're an intelligent trump
supporter,
which I do believe is possible,
you're a person who's not going to go to
a rally.
You have,
you have a job.
Jimmy Brady,
he's a fucking iron man.
He's a firefighter in New York.
He's fucking got three kids,
a lot of the New York city fire fire
department and Police Department
supported trump.
He ain't going to no fucking trump
rallies.
I mean he's,
you know,
he's a fucking really smart cat and,
and,
and
those people are lost people and they
found their hero and this,
the problem with a guy like trump is,
he's like,
he's an asshole,
but like he's an asshole on purpose.
Like this is part of his shtick is you
attack me,
I'll attack you back,
you know,
and he starts making fun of Rosie
O'donnell or making fun of this.
Had Amanda,
we knew how to deal with people like did
you see his whole shit that they put in
the 13th?
And like,
you know,
he was talking to the black people that
were in the fucking.
We knew the cops knew how to deal with
these guys back back in the day,
punch him in the face,
Kinnaman,
and then they were.
He's inciting a lot of this shit going
rabble rouser.
Yeah,
I mean,
that's part of being an asshole.
Divide and conquer,
divide and conquer.
If they could keep the people fighting
each other over stupid shit,
then you're not going to take the time
to sit back.
I compare those,
you know,
what's really going on?
I,
I use the analogy of,
of a magician.
They're trying to tell you,
look what's in the left hand,
but what the real shit is in the right
hand.
So by doing all this shit and causing
all these problems,
you're not going to go back and look at
the shit that he's pushing through his
agendas.
He just cut taxes to the fucking
enriches people that,
uh,
the billionaires and cooperation,
which he said he wasn't going to do.
He's gone back on everything.
So if he could just get people,
fuck you and fuck you.
And getting people to hate each other
and keep this country is to United
States of America.
When the fuck,
how did we become united as a country
like I think a lot of these countries
right now who may pose a threat or
whatever,
they're seeing what the fuck's going on
and they're like,
Yo,
this country has never been more fucking
divided.
It's divided states of America,
not the United States of America.
Well,
what he's doing with these,
these rallies is he's getting people
excited about being a part of a team and
a team that's winning.
You know,
like where the team is kicking ass and
this is team fake news over there.
You tell them to go fuck themselves and
nobody gets Ya,
Ya,
Ya.
He's consolidating his support.
He and it doesn't have to make sense and
especially it doesn't have to make sense
with the people that are going to these
rallies because they're not smart people
in the first place.
There are people that are easily led,
but that's the same thing with people
that would go to the rallies for Hillary
Clinton.
There are people that go to the rallies
for almost all these people.
A giant chunk of them are just,
they're just lemmings.
I don't know what to do.
I do have to hit one thing and that was
when fuck it and Hillary Clinton Clinton
was losing and the faces of the crying
people who were like fucking losing
their shit when trump won.
I was like,
I'm sorry,
but like fucking dude,
if that's the fucking truth of your
existence that you put every fucking
ounce of your shit into this fucking
corrupt as politician,
whether it's fucking Hillary Clinton or
Bernie Sanders on any of them.
I feel fucking sorry for you.
I was laughing at those people when she
lost,
enabled losing their shit on TV.
Like they were just fucking stand that.
I'm like,
because you don't realize I travel
through America and people may be
progressive on the outskirts,
but go into the middle.
It is motherfucker.
And see what you got fucking step voted
for that.
Yeah.
Well there was also people realize that
she was corrupt.
I mean,
you did a good job of calling her
corrupt
Hillary.
Absolutely.
The.
He just kept.
The mantra was going,
he loves mantras and he pushes those
fucking.
But they just had.
Yes.
Yeah,
correct.
So Tracy,
Bernie crazy burn,
he's
a,
he's a,
he's a good manipulator in that sense,
but she knows she didn't do any
services,
but there was also like a lot of the
women that were really upset where like
this guy was in that video saying you
take girls and grab them by the Pussy,
and so they,
they felt like this was going to give
men a licensed to be sexually abusive.
And I think that in a of ways is what
started the ball rolling with the me too
movement.
It wasn't just the exposing of monsters
like Bill Cosby,
but it was also the fact that you're
dealing with this guy who gets in the
White House.
That's clearly not what you want.
You want.
If it's a man,
you want a man who respects women,
who's a statesman,
who's a person who has worked their life
to get to that position.
Not a person who did it as an
afterthought once they were already
famous.
See,
like the difference between a guy like
Obama,
like Obama's probably.
He's probably measured his words ever
since he was in college because he was
hoping one day he would be president.
Whereas a guy like donald trump's just
been banging hoes and fucking flight
around the jet with his name on it since
the eighties.
I mean this is what the guy did.
So then once he's in office,
people like,
no,
I couldn't believe like how could this
have happened?
This is the pussy grabber.
He's not supposed to be in there and I
get their pain.
I understand it.
It is also funny.
No,
but something like the women's on her
knees with the glasses.
You ever seen a check with the
screaming.
She's like,
she's a meme.
She will.
She will again.
They made a,
they call it trump derangement syndrome
now because people are literally,
they're so angry that he is in power and
there's nothing they can do about it,
but the problem is that anger and that
that going derange that that empowers
the people that support him.
They don't understand when you're on
your knees screaming,
fuck the people on the other side of the
trump supporters,
their fucking red hats on.
They think that's hilarious.
This is the liberal left,
unhinged,
detached from reality.
Meanwhile,
we're making America great again and
black unemployment is at an all time low
and you know,
it's,
it's a weird time for the truth because
there's so many people that don't want
to go any further past the surface that
the truth is this guy figured out a way
to win a rigged system.
He did.
He figured out a way,
uh,
when a rig system by pretending to be a
republican guy was a democrat his whole
life,
democratic supporters his whole life
figured out a way.
Oh,
just puck a,
be a Republican.
They're easier to scam weaseled his way
in,
figured out a way.
This whole make America great again.
Yeah.
Ra,
call people a bunch of stupid shit
campaign like a motherfucker.
Take Diet pills,
keep that energy high.
Just travel all across the country doing
these rallies and one,
you know,
and want a system that really shouldn't
be there to win.
And I think that we need a better way to
run our government.
And the idea is fucking genius.
Having an Alpha male or Alpha female,
that one person,
the one at the top of the peak running
$300,
million people's insane 300 people's
insane.
You have 300 people,
one person running shit.
You're going to have disagreements.
You're going to have people that are
upset that this one person gets to
dictate for the next four to eight
years.
The path of everyone in this group and
your financial future,
your health care,
your.
You're all these how much taxes you pay,
all depending on what dipshit winds the
popularity contest.
That's outrageous.
It's an archaic way of handling things.
It's just not necessary,
but the problem with letting everybody
vote too is that people are really
easily manipulated and they're really
undereducated people.
They don't have any incentive to pay
attention to the real issues and what's
at stake and what the consequences of
each vote are.
They just vote with whatever feels good
and they're busy and people are tired
because they're eating shitty food and
exercise and they're working all day in
a job that sucks and they come home,
their wives,
Bitch Adam and they're on
antidepressants and pills and there the
kids are all fucked up and they don't
have the time.
They don't have the time and they don't
have the incentive to be enlightened.
They don't have the incentive to have an
objective in lightened approach to how
you handle the future of our society and
what our children are going to be left
with.
Well,
that's why it's the genius of these
commercials if you.
I mean it's.
I,
I can't even watch TV when it's election
time because it's just like one dude
after the next shitting on each other or
this person saying that we should mark
them for you.
It's like the two things that you get
when that shit goes on.
One of those political commercials in
into was all the commercials for the
pharmaceuticals,
but that's every fucking night.
There's two countries on earth,
New Zealand,
and America is where you're allowed to
direct advertising to customers,
to patients.
What the fuck is that race?
Is that crazy?
And I love the commercials now where the
dude figures it out.
Well,
you asked about Warfarin and I'd be
happy because people were walking down
the street and you see cartoon flowers
around them and butterflies and now if
your antidepressants is not working,
fine,
we'll fix that up.
A side effects include suicidal thought.
It's like motherfucker.
I had suicidal thoughts before.
Like Roche's,
rectal bleeding,
know some of the side effects are crazy.
It's fucking insane.
Vilifies the.
It's an anti psychotic.
It's the number one prescribed
medication in the country.
Abilify,
abilify,
really?
Number one.
Prescribed medication.
The country.
Wow.
It's an anti psychotic fuck.
Yeah.
What?
Insane.
I know you're like,
what?
That's insane.
Pull that up.
Make sure that's true.
I know I read that,
but make sure that it's true.
Somebody talked about that on the
podcast.
Who Was it?
Do you remember article in Twenty 15
saying it is the America's top selling
drug.
Pinson,
anti-psychotic,
Yo.
Abilify is the biggest,
biggest selling prescription jug and the
US is a fucking pill.
Damn top seller.
A drug has to be expensive.
It's also widely used.
Holly's abilify is both expensive and
wildly used.
It's the 14th prescribed brand name
medication and it retails for $30 a
pill.
So it's the biggest selling prescription
drug in the US.
So it's the biggest thing in,
of WHO's behind it.
It's a good question.
Who is behind it?
Put Satan.
Satan pharmaceuticals.
America's top selling drug.
I best like abilify.
It's terrifying.
Fishel site.
Let's see.
Scumbag.
They're the worst.
Did you ever read confessions of Duka?
Did you ever read Sukha?
Sukha,
Sukha.
They're probably,
they probably changed names.
Cloud,
they do keep switching up their names.
You ever did?
Well,
now they,
uh,
they changed a fucking,
what do you call it to,
um,
changing the name on all these
ingredients that are in food to like,
um,
what is the,
uh,
the additive,
the sweetener that Donald Aspartame,
aspartame,
they changed their name to Aminos suite
now because you know,
who owns the patent on fucking as
aspartame didn't.
Donald,
Rumsfeld,
Donald Rumsfeld had something to do with
it.
Own Stat.
Well,
you had something to do with passing it.
Yeah.
He had something to do with ignoring
evidence,
but see,
someone told me that the amount of
chemicals they had to give to rats,
the amount of aspartame,
they had to give the rats to kill them
or to give them cancer was very high and
I'm like,
okay,
that's good.
That's reassuring,
but there's a great book about the
corruption of the pharmaceutical
companies and it's a.
can you google this title real quick?
It's called confessions of Gwen Olson
wrote a book called confessions of an Rx
drug pusher and I think it was her niece
died of a drug interaction that they
knew about and she exposed the whole
corruption in the pharmaceutical
industry.
She was a top pharmaceutical rep and
they said they know how does a drug get
approved by the FDA and then they turn
around and fucking they pull it and
people are dying and they settle for
pennies on the dollar.
That's the fucking game.
They know there's going to be lawsuits
and they're like,
okay,
we just made $3,000,000,000 off this
drug and we settled that lawsuit for
$200 billion.
So that's a hundred million,
200 million.
Right?
So that's the game.
That's.
But her book is amazing.
It's called confessions of an Rx drug
pusher and that's what she was.
And she would buy out the doctors.
Half the people that they put on these
medications,
all they have to say is change your
fucking lifestyle,
dude.
What is,
what is the father of modern medicine?
Hypocrisy is,
what did he say?
Let thy food be thy medicine and
medicine be thy food.
There's also an IRA.
Vedic,
I don't know if you know about the Irish
vedic system of Madison and it says
when,
uh,
you know,
there's a whole quote about diet and,
and made it and,
and uh,
and,
uh,
seeing a
doctor and stuff like that.
And it's all,
it comes back to one thing,
man.
Diet and lifestyle.
Like what the fuck are you doing?
Tell people.
And that's what's great about a movie
like forks over knives where there's
anecdotal evidence that says,
Yo,
if you stopped,
do you see the change right there?
The fucking diabetes goes away,
the fucking heart disease,
all,
all of this stuff is,
uh,
is cured by the fact that these people
get to assets moving and they stopped
eating all this shitty food.
Yeah.
Shitty food is the number one problem is
the number one problem.
Sugar,
refined carbohydrates,
your body processing massive amounts of
stuff that it's not supposed to get in.
Everything boils in everything.
And you know,
all these processed vegetable oils like
cooking things in
all that stuff.
And People Think,
oh,
you know,
even to assert
what do you got here,
Jeremy?
Donald run.
So the FDA actually banned aspartame
based on his findings,
only to have cereal chairman Donald
Rumsfeld,
currently secretary of defense at the
time they wrote this article,
vow to call in his markers to get it
approved on January 21st 1991 the day
after Ronald Reagan's inauguration.
Cyril,
I guess that's c a r l e reapply to the
FDA for approval to use aspartame.
And food sweetener and Reagan's new FDA
Commissioner Arthur Hayes Hall junior
appointed a five person scientific
commission to review the board of
inquiry.
Decision became clear.
The panel would uphold the band by a
three to two to two decision,
but then hold,
then install the sixth member on the
commission and the vote became
deadlocked.
He then personally broke the tie and
aspartame favor what a piece of shit.
But this is,
this puts,
they found evidence.
This shit makes holes in the brain.
It might induce the.
The evidence grains might induce
migraine tumors.
Right?
And the thing is now everyone got hipped
to aspartame.
Now you have to read because that's why
the process.
Food is so fucking any of that here,
that fake sweetness shit.
And now they call it amino suite is the
new name that they changed it to.
So.
Well you,
you.
Do you ever drink your drinks?
Soda,
Soda sweetened with Stevia.
Stevia.
It's fucking delicious.
Stevia's from plants.
It's a sweetener and people don't like
it,
great taste of Stevia.
It tastes good.
But I do have too much protein powders
that have a,
you know,
a Stevia in it and stuff.
Clean machine has a protein powder
that's a lentin and uh,
the water lentils,
they call them.
It's real,
real clean.
Yeah.
Are on it.
Hemp force protein.
We were using Stevia.
Stevia for that.
I've called Stevia nuts,
debbie.
But that title potato,
which just doesn't taste the same,
tastes good.
It's a matter
of.
But it's so potent.
The problem is like if people have a cup
of coffee,
I would have stevie out and people put
it in there and be like,
oh,
I'd be like,
you put too much in.
He can't put it in like sugar.
That's way more potent.
You just need a tiny dash.
Like even back in the day,
I remember my mom being like,
oh,
Yay,
nutrasweet and this and that.
Let's put all these other like,
cane sugar is better for you than these
fucking fake sweeteners.
Sugar still terrible for you.
Terrible for you.
You're not close as a sugar daddy in the
body.
You're going to do sugar.
You should do eat fruit.
Come to the fibers in your body,
slowly digesting it,
which is the way you're supposed to
consume it,
but you'd be able to get like a
gatorade.
It's got like fucking 80 grams of sugar
and they're like,
that shit's terrible for you.
All that stuff terrible for you.
Soda,
and they got all the pros pushing it.
Like these kids,
you go to these a basketball camp,
so football cancel or whatever,
or high schools and what are they
drinking?
They're all drinking,
drinking the Koolaid.
Well,
you know what,
if you're exerting yourself like very
strenuously,
you could use some of that glucose and
that's okay,
but for the average person that goes to
a fucking 7:11 and gets a big gulp and
his downing,
you know,
64 ounces of Coca Cola,
that is a crazy amount of sugar for your
body to get in one serving.
Your body doesn't know what to do with
that shit.
So it stores it as fat.
What I forget how many tablespoons of
sugar they said he's in one of them.
Fucking a big gulp.
Do they did a thing where they showed
all the various sizes of soda next to
have the sugar and you see the actual,
the actual sugar.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
This is our number one problem and one
of the things that I did when I cut
sugar out of my died,
there it is.
There's the image that's a kilo of coke
son,
sides of that.
That's so much sugar.
Your body doesn't know what the fuck's
going on when you take that much sugar
and it's insane and it's freaking thing
is.
You got kids jacked up on that all day
long.
Bouncing off the wall.
Yeah,
and then they put them on Ritalin
because Johnny's got too much energy.
Johnny's on drugs.
Yes.
Sugar drug
long.
Yeah.
I mean,
and then on top of that,
here's one of the problems with people
consuming that kind of stuff and then on
top of it's saturated fat or your kids
set.
See,
there's studies now that are showing
that cholesterol and saturated fat are
healthy for your diet and healthy for
your body in less.
You're consuming carbohydrates and
refined sugars because when you're doing
that,
then your body's not burning fat,
so your body is just storing fat and on
top of that you're pouring massive
amounts of sugar in there,
so you're getting hardening of the
arteries and clogging of the arteries
and people think that this is.
They're conflating and confusing all
this and thinking,
well,
this is because you're eating
cholesterol and saturated fat.
Nope,
it's not.
It's because you're eating cholesterol
and saturated fat along with simple
carbohydrates,
refined carbohydrates and sugars.
There's a chemical reaction that your
body has that when you're eating these
two things together becomes toxic.
It's
dangerous night.
Trust Semites as well.
When you say that's the average American
diet,
and then combine it with alcohol and the
rest of this stuff,
it creates a a chemical reaction in the
body that then causes a problems for you
health wise and your immune system and
gut health and everything else.
Yeah,
there's A.
There's a ton of problems with people's
bodies and you could trace it back to a
host of different things.
You could.
You could trace it back to pesticides.
You could trace it back to a lack of
minerals.
You can trace it back to excess sugar,
you can trace it back to processed
vegetable oils,
you can trace it back to sedentary
lives.
There's so many different things that
are a factor in people's health issues,
but one of the problems with ideologies,
whether it's this carnivore diet
ideology or Vegan Diet audiology,
is people want to look at one thing.
There's one thing that's wrong and you
fix this thing,
and if you just do this one thing,
you're going to be healthy.
That's not necessarily the case,
and there's a lot of people out there on
both sides that are spreading
misinformation because it supports their
view.
It supports their bias positioning
studies that were funded by the same
companies that are making money off of
selling foods that are high in saturated
fats or cholesterol or trans fats,
trans fats in it.
There's companies.
So you always have to look between the
fucking lines.
That's where the truth lies because the
milk industries.
What was the other,
uh,
the other documentary that came out,
um,
fuck it was about.
It started with the cigarettes and the
uh,
and the chemicals that they were using
in furniture day.
There was this documentary to,
and I always blank on it.
I'm fucking old man brain and I have.
It was a documentary about how they paid
these people to put out false
information.
I know you're talking about merchants of
death,
merchants of doubt,
amazing fucking shame.
People that are doubting climate change.
We're also touting cigarettes being
addicted the same
and they're using the same tactics that
they've been using and to push the
chemicals and put.
They had motherfuckers spraying DDT on
their fucking clothes hanging in their
closet to stop moths.
Can you fucking believe that shit,
dude,
it's in that.
It's in the way they had them spraying
fucking Dick Cancer causing chemicals on
this shit.
When you see those guys have the same
guys that were trying to say that
cigarettes are not,
they're not addictive and the same
people that are there,
there were dismissing climate change.
You're like,
what?
Like,
how can you be so obvious?
You don't even use new people.
They,
they,
they did the thing with the guy from
Monsanto and roundup,
because I would drink fucking roundup
and he.
Okay,
I'm going to go get you a fucking glass.
Here's a glass of fucking drink,
like drink it.
He's like,
nope.
Who does this?
Jamie?
Is that DDT wallpaper?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Look at that.
Containing Ddt as the active
insecticide,
genuine cedar wood made into wallpaper.
So these people made DDT closet
wallpaper with fucking,
with genuine cedar wood.
Well,
the other thing is,
even the chemicals that they put in the
furniture,
there's a big thing now to remove
because it's calming the fucking
children.
Do you know that rugs and furniture
actually will release chemicals into the
air in your house.
Oh,
you have this protective.
Sure.
Children's against disease carrying
insects,
DDT,
children's room,
wallpaper.
How many kids got cancer from that shit?
Crazy fucking bed is so insane.
Kills insects.
Mosquitoes,
flies.
Ants.
And you,
you know,
one of the biggest,
one of the.
One of the biggest ways that toxins
enter the body is not by walking around
the streets of La or New York and
breathing into pollution.
It's the fucking home,
the amount of chemicals that are in the
fucking home,
and they talk about that in merchants of
doubt to chemicals in the furniture,
the chemicals in the closed,
the chemicals in the fucking diapers to
chemicals in everything in the plastic.
It's chemicals,
chemicals,
chemicals.
You're bombarding your fucking child
with fucking dozens and dozens of
chemicals every fucking day.
And while it's immune throughout that
child's immune system is developing and
then you're feeding it pesticides,
you're feeding it.
This fucking animal that's been
tortured.
It's whole life and Fed fucking steroids
and hormones.
And you're wondering why these kids are
coming out and they're so fucked because
it's when they're getting into their
teens,
it's because all of that shit's taken a
toll.
Not just physically,
but you know,
psychologically it's fucking,
it's,
you know,
then,
there's so much other shit they're doing
to,
to the,
to the food put in,
put in.
Um,
there's an episode,
you know,
that they put in the corn and the soy
now and it's fucking,
uh,
it was done by this company in La and
they will,
oh,
I was down in California somewhere,
episode e p I c Dot y,
t,
and it fucks with the sexual
reproduction organs of,
of fetuses and children and all kinds of
shit they do.
They're conducting like fucking mad
science on human beings right now.
What the fuck is going on?
Just for profit even in Hawaiian,
I got to tell you,
I have friends that are out there and
they did organic farming,
organic farming.
Do you know that?
All the world seed banks right now for
GMO or fucking grown in Hawaii
because of it's a closed ecosystem
that's closed off from everywhere else.
So there's no other factors.
So they go and they spray motherfucking
chem trails,
the air
that calmed down onto the fucking ground
and they can,
for instance,
and I wait a minute,
what do they do?
They're spraying aerosol spraying the
crops.
So the aerosol,
so some sort of.
So what they do and they do aluminum.
Barium,
strontium.
Now I'm going to tell you,
I have,
I have friends that actually are doing
this.
They were aghast farmers and I had to
give up their farm and what they do is
they make the,
to the uh,
the making the soil so acidic the Ph,
then nothing will grow except for
genetically modified seeds that have
been genetically modified to resist
aluminum and resist all this other
stuff.
So now the spraying aluminum,
like where's that coming from?
It's,
it makes it,
makes the soil various civic it,
it changes the Ph.
I think aluminum has the greatest,
a change to the soil and what's the
benefit of them doing that because then
they can control the food supply because
if you don't buy the GMO seeds,
the organic farmers are going out of
business in Hawaii.
And this ain't no,
wait a minute.
So you're saying that they're spreading
things out of the sky that poisoned the
ground so that only organic farmers are
so that only gmo farmers can grow crops
there.
Right?
That's proven.
That's what's going on.
And it sounds crazy though,
but here's the thing,
and I'm not saying they're going like
some of these other camp trail people,
$35,000,
they're spraying all the cities I'm
spraying.
I'm saying that coming in and spraying
chemicals on the ground,
but they're not doing it as a pesticide.
You're saying they're doing it as a
grand conspiracy to make the ground
infertile for anything.
Do you ever read Monsanto's.
Did you ever see the world according to
Monsanto?
Okay.
So what do they say?
We want to control the world's food
supply from seed to motherfucking to
farm to table,
all the way through.
We want to control.
So how did they do that?
How do they actually make that happen?
And I see it happening to farmers in
Hawaii and friends of mine are ag.
I just did ironman.
What do you see happening?
Because what they're doing,
the,
the organic Papaya farmers have had to
all go either give up their farm or go
switch to a GMO Papaya because none of
their shit is growing.
It's just that because the depletion of
the soil,
not it's,
but they say that the fucking day
spraying the chemicals on the soil,
but do you know how much they'd have to
spray on the soil to make it infertile?
It's much more likely candidate to the
same issues that we're having in this
country with mono crops that they're
just depleting their soil because
they're constantly growing on it.
No,
because these guys are doing organic
study chem trails that study chem trails
for quite a while because I was doing a
television show on them and one of the
things that I found with this,
this is a lot of Malarkey.
Absolutely shit,
and one of the things that they find is
they're like,
oh,
they're
spraying aluminum and then when they do
samples of the water,
they find aluminum in the water.
Now they're doing samples of sludge.
This do samples of water with dirt.
Do you know with one of the most common
metals that you'll ever find on earth is
aluminum.
Aluminum.
Most dirt has aluminum in it,
so when they're testing this water,
they're testing positive for aluminum.
What they're doing is it tested dirt,
dirt tested positive for being dirt.
That's what it is.
So when they find a aluminum,
they say,
oh my God,
they're spraying aluminum.
There's no benefit to spraying aluminum
on anything.
It's never been proven that there's some
evil government cabal that wants to
spray aluminum on everything and that's
the reason why papayas don't grow.
Right.
It's way more likely that these papayas
are growing in a place where they've
been grown papayas for a long time and
they've depleted the soil,
especially dealing with soil that's
really coming out of a volcano in the
first place.
Well,
I mean I understand that aspect of it,
but it's the combination of other
chemicals that they're using.
And here's the thing.
Before these seed banks showed up over
there,
they never had this problem.
There's also before large scale
agriculture made its way to Hawaii as
well,
right?
So they probably had years and years and
years of doing this and getting away
with it to the soil started getting
depleted.
Just like we have evidence of it getting
depleted all over the world.
India,
they have issues with this,
with mono crops,
with anywhere in the world where they
grow crops in the same area,
in these massive scales,
you're going to deplete the ground of
minerals and nutrients.
I mean it's just a part of the problem
and when they offer up that solution
like,
hey,
our genetically modified crops are
better in are genetically,
you know,
people modified crops are,
they can survive in these harsh climates
and you can also add all of our nitrogen
and our fertilizers are nasty shit to
the.
Everything else around it will die when
we spray except for our crops because
we've been genetically engineered to
resist.
We been genetically engineered to
Yeah,
that's scary.
That glyphosate shit is any,
anything that kills everything.
But what you,
what you want it to is like what?
Like what's it doing to what you wanted
to.
What happens to that food?
What is that stuff out of that food by
the time you eat it?
Um,
I don't think so.
I don't think so either.
I mean,
when
it comes out in the leaves and the bugs
eat this shit and it blows their
stomach,
there's a
great documentary on it called what's
with wheat,
where they try to break down why wheat
all the sudden became a huge problem in
the American diet,
whereas in the early 19 hundreds it was
nothing and it was a slow genetic
modification where they.
They started changing the weed itself
and breeding it to make higher yields,
so it's got more complex gluten's in it,
but then on top of that,
it's the glyphosate.
The glyphosate breaks down your gut
barrier and people get leaky gut and the
rest of the yeah buts it kills the
bacteria.
I mean,
this is what they're trying to do that
trying to kill bacteria,
but they don't realize your made out
of bacteria.
Your body's an ecosystem of bacteria,
right?
Yeah.
That's just the problem with the whole
government is evil thing is they're just
greedy or evil because they're greeting,
right?
Yeah.
Thing and,
and you saw the world according to
Monsanto and it's this revolving door
policy.
How they come at a massage,
Monsanto or even what he was doing,
Rumsfeld,
when he was the CEO of Searle.
And then so they get into the
government,
they pass legislation and they go back
to the corporations to reap the benefits
of the laws that they passed.
You have a lot of that going on.
So I think,
uh,
you know,
whether or not she could really be what
the fuck motherfuckers is saying it is
in Hawaii or anywhere else and the truth
is going to possibly come out eventually
or maybe not,
but me personally,
I tend to try to stick to locally farmed
organic like I go to the farm is mark,
how do you get it in New York?
This farmer's market from upstate and
yeah,
they could.
They come up,
they come into the city.
Um,
I mean I'm,
I'm not going to bullshit.
I go to a health food store and eat shit
that's out of season because I like my
fucking Broccoli and Kale or whatever
the fuck and some fruit or whatever.
But um,
you know,
how do they grow that stuff,
shipped it shipped in from Cali.
And in Florida,
I mean,
you know,
it's not the best,
but hey,
when you take into equation the fact
that I've eliminated this,
this,
the other foods that used the highest
amount of fossil fuels to grow the crops
and,
and everything else that's involved with
producing the,
a huge,
you know,
these farms that are,
that are,
uh,
these animal agriculture system than the
amount of fossil fuels.
I mean,
I had motherfuckers writing me,
you take a fucking plane and go on tour.
Fuck you.
Like the thing we were talking about
earlier,
fault every fucking thing,
you know.
But,
but a true though,
we all do.
Do you sda both
poisoned sky a little bit when we fly.
So,
hey,
you know,
I'll take,
I'll take the hit man.
We live in a real problem.
I mean that's one of the things they
found after September 11th with the lack
of plane flights changed the Earth's
temperature.
I mean,
it's fucking nuts,
man.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
The also the cloud cover that's created
by contracts like that cools the earth
down a little bit.
It's very interesting.
They've admitted to it.
The government has actually admitted to
a program to try to sprain shit,
to try to
cool the earth's well.
They've admitted to experimented with
weather manipulation and to,
to having strategies for dealing with
it,
whether it is for dealing with hostile
foreign governments where trying to
starve them out or trying to put
rain.
I mean they've been around forever.
We have a space.
Would you see the fucking video?
Hey guys made on space for now.
What is it?
Is it funny?
It's fucking hilarious.
They,
they,
uh,
it's on youtube.
The spool on,
on trump's space.
It's fucking.
But here's the thing.
It's like China repair is trying to
patch a shotgun wound with a bandaid.
Like let's reduce the fossil fuel.
If you want to fucking cool the earth
and everything and save the fucking
oceans and all the rest of this shit.
It's why don't we check how the fuck we
live our lives.
But everybody wants to pass the buck and
say,
oh,
well why should I do it?
You know,
let the next motherfucker do it.
But you know,
you buy what you put in your car and how
you live your life and you have fucking
how many people in America?
$200.
How many?
Three hundred million.
$300.
Fucking million motherfuckers passing
the buck along.
You're not getting anywhere.
And China's how many billion in India?
And it's like they're not fucking,
they're not going to stop fucking doing
what they're doing.
No,
no they're not.
And it's again,
it's like what we were talking about
with all the other aspects of gigantic
culture.
There's so many moving pieces.
It's so,
it's so difficult because we're,
we're talking about these pieces that
have been in place for decades and so to
try to make corrections now and you
know,
and some people are,
they are going to organic farms.
They are going to raising their own food
and having it,
you know,
having everything be local.
And that's definitely better.
But the real problem it seems to me is
overpopulation.
And the real problem is when you jam,
you know,
Los Angeles is a perfect example.
There's 200 million people just here in
it just to get a million,
excuse me,
20 million,
20 million people.
That's ridiculous.
20 million people just here and then
there's Orange County which has more
people.
San Diego has more people as you get
north of people in San Francisco because
we got like morning.
He people fucking millionaire.
There's more people.
There's more people in California just
in Santa,
just in La.
The more people in Los Angeles than
there is in all of Australia.
Just all just insane.
So there's so many people and no one's
grown anything other than we just weeds
being grown here and that's it.
So all the food is being shipped in from
everywhere else and so you've got fossil
fuels being used and then
you pay more in Hawaii for a fucking
pineapple.
Then you do on the mainland.
That crazy dude.
It's fucking insane.
You haven't been there.
How expensive for cat food?
Everything's very expensive.
Fucking insane.
It's a beautiful,
beautiful place though and that's why
people are willing to take that hit.
We.
We live in a place that humans like
yourself and myself and people that are
alive today,
we are stuck in a system that was
created many,
many decades ago.
It was put into place many decades ago
and it wasn't put into place with our
interests in mind.
It was put into place with the interest
mind a profit,
and it was also to deal with the,
to accommodate millions and millions of
people that are all jammed into one
place where no one's growing any food.
It's a very unnatural way to live.
You know,
they started coming down on all the
people fucking growing a shade on their
front lawns and yards now because urban
organic farm into,
you know,
I'm,
I'm in touch with a lot of those people.
As a matter of fact,
there's one in,
in New York City I ride from New York
city out to like Long Island Jones beach
and all that.
And I pass in far rockaway.
It is a guy that he's doing like a big
urban farm.
The in this thing and you know,
in this crop of land,
and uh,
you know,
it's the urban farming is becoming a big
thing because if I it the food desert
is,
and there was one guy on abc and he
walked home from work every night and it
was five miles African American guy and
he's trying to lose weight and get
healthy.
Well,
guess what?
Every motherfucking night all he passed
was KFC.
This,
that,
the other thing,
7:11.
He could not buy a fucking piece of
fruit or a fucking apple in any of those
fucking places.
None.
So then they said,
well,
how the fuck are we going to get food if
we ain't got no car,
we can go seven,
10 miles out of town to the supermarket.
So now urban,
organic farming is becoming a big thing
where they're showing these pen,
now they're starting to crack down.
The cities are trying to crack down on
these people that are growing fucking
food.
That's ridiculous.
Crazy.
I had Ron Finley on this podcast and
he's got a similar program in south
central and uh,
he helps these kids and people that live
there use vacant lots.
Use Medians in Detroit too.
Yeah,
it's fantastic.
Yeah.
Grow food.
You got all fucking fruit.
Food would be free.
Grow it,
grow it.
And Patches of land.
I mean,
what would be ideal is if every
community,
instead of just having a house jam next
to a house,
gym next to a house,
every community have one community lot
and that community lot.
We all grow our food in,
you know,
not hard to do.
I mean even in a fucking closet did,
showing how to do like they just had
this,
they had a shipping container in New
York and it was a demonstration and they
put it on a Lafayette and Lafayette
Street and Houseton and it was a
shipping container and they did all.
And when you walked in there,
it was a fucking farm and I forget how
many thousand pounds of organic produce
that,
that fucking farm inside that shipping
container was able to grow.
But it's insane.
No,
that's the artificial light.
But you could do that with real life,
the real streets that you see everywhere
you go,
what,
where concrete is,
it could be dirt and then it is possible
that we could cordon off a small section
of every community and have a community
garden and it would also be a good.
It would be good for the community in
terms of people interacting with each
other and feeling like they're a part of
something and taking responsibility for
taking care of.
Get your hands in the dirt too,
man.
You know,
it's,
it's very,
like,
that's one of the programs that we did
in this documentary.
We added a guy's going to fall organic
farms and getting their hands in the
dirt and seeing,
you know,
people just as a disconnect between
like,
you know,
farmers man,
I gotTa,
you know,
it's like that's a fucking hard ass
fucking job.
Fucking hard ass job.
Fucking hard man.
We don't show the appreciation.
And I think who was the,
um,
the one black activists who used to run
the marathons and shit.
He forget his name in the sixties and
Gregory Dick fucking Gregory,
man.
He always talked about,
you know,
growing your own fucking food and,
and
no Dick Gregory's the guy who brought
the Zapruder film to television is
approved or film of Kennedy being
assassinated.
It looks like he's being shot from the
front.
What?
Yes.
Dick Gregory brought that to the Geraldo
Rivera show.
Wow.
Years after the assassination.
It might've been more.
More than eight.
Might have been more.
Know a lot of shit.
Yeah.
The,
it might've been 10 years after the
assassin.
Something crazy,
but it didn't.
People didn't see Kennedy get
assassinated until many,
many,
many years after when this guy's
approved or who was there on the spot
was filming.
They took his,
his film and he sold it to time life
magazine.
They use stills of it and then they
didn't show it.
What,
12 years?
Twelve years later.
Seventy five.
Wow.
So on 75 and the Geraldo Rivera show,
they,
they premiered the Zapruder film footage
of the assassination of President
Kennedy from like fucking 20 yards away.
He was right.
That NDC Kennedy's head go back into the
left.
It's,
you see the spray of blood and you're
like,
what?
So was it,
did they show that it was more than one?
They can't tell for sure and there's a
lot of speculation because there's so
many men in black and white and they
were shaky back then.
They've since use computers to stabilize
the image,
but what it looks like to the untrained
eye is that he shot more than once and
probably shot from multiple different
angles and the reason why they came up
with the magic bullet theory,
because they account,
they had to account for another bullet
that didn't hit the president.
They had to account for a bullet that
hit it ricocheted under an underpass and
hit a guy.
So yeah,
the bullet had to go through to people
and it had a leave traces of the bullet
behind that weren't missing for the
bullet from the book.
And it had a shattered bone and not
distort.
Which doesn't happen.
Yeah.
If you know anything about bullets,
if you shoot anything,
bullets get Jack.
They get,
they tear up.
They,
they been,
they get,
they get sleep.
Yeah.
You could take fucking lead.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Even if it's jacketed,
it's still going to get fucked up.
It's hitting bones and shattering at a
ridiculous speed.
The single bullet theory was also
created by Arlen Specter and those
fucking guys from the Warren Commission
report,
bunch of evil assets
is a great book on it called a best
evidence by David Lifton.
David Lipton was an accountant who went
over the Warren Commission report step
by step every step of the way,
and she found all these contradictions
in the reporting like this is a bullshit
document like when they were trying to
do was just wrapped this bitch up nice
and tight.
They weren't trying to solve the crime.
They were trying to wrap this thing up
tight and the most ridiculous aspect of
it is the magic bullet theory,
but before anybody saw this uproot or
film,
it didn't look that ridiculous.
We heard what we were told.
Kennedy got shot by Oswald and Jack Ruby
shot ours walled.
Very convenient,
very convenient.
The whole thing is ridiculous.
I don't know why they killed them,
but it's very likely that there was
quite a few people involved and not just
Lee Harvey Oswald,
and he was probably involved.
Well,
you know,
that he passed a resolution.
He was fucking with the Federal Reserve.
Oh yeah.
What was the,
uh,
one one one.
Uh,
it was a.
well,
there's a lot of problems.
They have pigs.
Hey,
a pig.
Yeah.
There was a,
he wanted to get rid of the Federal
Reserve.
He wanted to get rid of the CIA.
Started printing.
Nope.
A currency backed by.
He wanted to go back to the gold,
silver standard.
He started printing up notes.
Fucking if you could find those notes
from when he was in silver certificates.
And he said,
why a private banks controlling our
money,
the Federal Reserve.
It wasn't,
I think one of the acts that,
uh,
George Bush junior passed before he
left,
or this executive order on one one,
one zero to give him the printing of the
money back to the fucking take it away
from the Federal Reserve.
They whacked him just a couple of months
later and give it back to the secretary.
His father said that they're going to
kill you for this.
His father told him that you fuck with
them.
Bankers,
man.
True.
It's uh,
you know,
comes back to,
to,
you know,
power is not about a conspiracy.
It's about Yo.
It's about,
they want the ultimate greed.
It's the ultimate greed.
We control everything.
Well,
especially back then
then.
I mean,
the amount of accountability that
politicians had back then you can get
away with a lot.
There was a lot of wiggle room and you
know,
it's most likely that somebody other
than just Lee Harvey Oswald and he
probably had something to do with it
too.
I mean,
he was
probably Manchurian candidate.
It's man,
who knows,
they grabbed these guys.
They fucking.
Who knows does what within,
you know,
they're still doing it.
I believe to this day know a lot of
these fucking motherfuckers trying to
fucking shoe bombers and this fucking
clown and this,
you know,
there's so much shit going on.
Like even the shoe bomber,
like who the fuck did he get on a plane
with no passport?
You know,
it's like there's so much shit to just
go home.
Well you remember that God,
that they busted in Dallas,
who is a god that they'd set up.
They set him up to be an Islamic
terrorist.
They trained him,
they gave him the weapon and then as he
was trying to detonate the weapon,
they arrested him.
It's like you guys talked him into doing
this,
you gave him the bombs and then you
arrested him.
Like what would he have done if you guys
weren't even there?
We've done anything.
They,
they,
they thought that this guy was a person
who was suspicious.
So they literally set up an entrapped
him
entrapment.
It's Kinda going on.
It's going on a lot,
man.
It's fucking like we don't even notice
shit that's going on behind the walls of
the fucking offices.
Man.
It was fucking scared of fucking
Bejesus.
Addy.
If he knew,
you know,
what the fuck was,
uh,
you know what?
These people's minds,
you know,
well you get accustomed to make and
rationalizations that will cross people
their lives and I think anybody that can
send a drone to shoot down an apartment
building because of Metadata,
you know,
you found the metadata that seems to
indicate that the cell phone of a
certain criminal is on the 14th floor.
Let the fucking hell fire missiles fly
baby.
Yeah,
I mean that's decisions that they make.
That's Virginia city x box controller.
Fucking like,
you know,
disconnected from everything.
If you talked to someone from the CIA,
they tell you it's all lawyers who make
those decisions to lawyers do all the
calculations and they go,
yeah,
you can do it.
Crazy.
Crazy man.
Yeah,
dude,
we just did three hours a day.
We flew by.
Well,
you know what they say.
How do you know when a lawyer is lying?
His lips are moving.
Hey,
I got a good lawyer though.
Let me tell you,
this guy would be good lawyers.
There is good people,
good people.
Peter Nussbaum I love yet.
Shout out to Peter.
He just bombed my lawyer.
He's not a criminal attorney,
so come to the fights this weekend I was
invited.
I was like,
hopefully we get along and have a
fucking dope because we got along.
It was fine.
I have massive respect,
you know,
Brian's a crazy motherfucker.
I tell a story,
you know,
that whole school down there was I,
I wanted to tell her story about mine
because he
fucking.
He's hilarious.
I used to take A.
Tony
[inaudible] is one of the senior
students have mastered Choi.
Another guy,
we'll call him chuck,
but he's with the government now.
He's a fucking bad motherfucker.
So they always used to go around and,
and,
and want to fight balances and all this
shit.
That was what they did.
They would fucking fight the biggest
scariest looking motherfuckers and just
destroyed them.
So blue worked.
I said his name,
sorry,
but my friend worked with a cro mags and
stuff.
We took them out,
security with us in case we had problems
or whatever.
So it was like everything always went
smooth.
So one time I used to work at all the
underground hip hop clubs in New York.
So my friend was doing a party and it
was all fucking deep heads,
fucking like homeboys and shit,
like the real deal,
this hip hop club.
And I take Brian,
another dude from the school and Tony
and we go over there and Brian is in the
middle of the dance floor doing the
Funky fucking white boy nerd dance and
all these fuck.
And the floor just opens up and these
fucking black fucking hip hop crazy
fucking homeboys that like,
Yo,
look at this mother fucking white boy
like his bucket.
And he don't give a fuck.
He's less seriously,
like a fucking piss to roll with.
So then I might go,
uh,
I gotta go.
But listen man,
I know what y'all motherfuckers do.
Don't start.
No Shit,
please.
It's my friend's club.
So I get home,
go to sleep,
wake up the next day I get a fucking
phone call,
Yo.
Like he didn't know that they were with
me.
He's like,
Yo,
there was these three fucking karate
experts in the club last night.
And they beat up all my fucking
bouncers.
Dude.
It was fucking crazy.
Like and one bounce a walked up and
started some shit with a Tony was trying
to talk to a girl,
whatever.
And,
and then like,
you know,
this guys all on the juice,
rips off his shirt.
Like I fucking Tony throws a kick
fucking dislocates the guy's fucking
kneecap.
And then,
uh,
the melee just ensued in it.
It was just constant.
These fucking huge bouncers,
common Adam.
And Brian's like fucking prior could
fight.
Brian is a,
uh,
you know,
he's,
he's a comedian,
but he could throw down and then he,
Brian just told me this because I didn't
hear the other part.
He goes,
yeah.
Then all of a sudden I'm fucking whack
and these dudes and us with fight and
these guys and then this fucking
gigantic motherfucker.
Like I was just like a little fucking
baby in his arms,
lifts me up and carries me out the
fucking door and throws me across this
car.
And I look and I turned around and I'm
ready to go.
And then Brian says,
and I look and it's this fucking crazy
white dude with a fucking scar from one
end of his face down his throat and he
points at Brian Goes,
don't even think about it.
And like Brian was like,
Yo.
But my friend called me up the next day,
he's like,
these motherfuckers.
And I called them up and I'm like,
Brian,
the fuck did you do man?
I told you guys to fucking keep Chili's
like,
Yo,
these bouncers were assholes.
And you know,
he's,
he's a,
he's a character.
Like I said,
I was at his first comedy show ever.
He lived a wild life in his young days.
I met him after all that stuff.
I met him when he was more calm.
I met him in the nineties.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They were in big time master choice.
It was all about fucking getting out
there and fucking contact.
There was a lot of martial arts coaches
or instructors that wanted you to get in
street
fights because you had practice cause
it,
like street fights would show you how
things would work in the real world that
the more you did it,
the more you understood urgency,
closing the distance,
you know,
delivering the first strike,
all that kind of shit.
Like people are hesitant because
inspiring.
You always hold back.
So like,
you know,
I knew many more sites.
Quando background started.
Yeah.
Brian told me that about you.
He goes,
Yo,
I got kicked.
Like a fucking horse shit because I'll
see you on fear factor.
We want something before that to news
radio.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And,
and,
and he's like,
yeah,
I know.
That's my dude man.
He fucking,
you know,
he's like,
Yo,
you fucking ben the bag in half.
And so I,
you know,
I,
respect for foot at,
you know,
I was like that's a bad motherfucker.
But uh,
listen,
we're going to have some fun this
weekend.
Fights are going to be awesome.
It's a sick card size.
You know,
I've been found the UFC since day one
and originally,
and when that first came around,
it was the gracies that put a fucking.
Dave took out an ad in a karate karate
magazines and they said we will take
anybody $100,000 if they can beat us.
That's,
I saw UFC one rem co pardot and dude,
I've been watching that shit since day
one.
Uh,
you know,
into a live one.
No.
Oh,
perfect.
I went to a who to Douglas Crosby,
who was the judge very well.
Doug Doug's my man dog,
worked with the chromatics.
Took me to some fights and stuff.
And uh,
in Jersey actually I did go to a live
one.
Uh,
Jake from rocks off took me to the UFC
when it was in newark and there was
fucking fights breaking out was this,
this was probably like four or five
years ago in Newark,
a down,
you know,
they,
they have UFC in Newark.
And I went to that and uh,
there was a fight on the main floor.
That was the best fight of the night.
These two fucking guys just started,
you know.
And then when you left,
everyone's doing good in school.
Every fucking Rama.
Luke got a school and a flyer.
That's how I love to fight the fights.
You know,
I've been watching the boxing matches
since the seventies.
All the super fights.
Fucking Muhammad Ali and Ken Norton and
Fucking,
uh,
what was the great one?
Hagler hearns.
Yeah.
I'm trying
Marvin Hagler on the podcast now.
He's like the only guy that retired
clean.
He's like,
I'm good at last to sugar ray Leonard.
Last decision that a lot of people
thought he should have won that fight.
It's just like this done walked away.
No one ever done that.
Made a hitman.
Her boxing used to be like,
you know,
I just posted a picture of Mike Tyson,
Jake Lamata and um,
and fucking Graziano on my,
on my instagram.
Like those three cars.
My father boxed at gramercy gym,
which was run by custom motto,
which they knocked it down.
It was right near the palladium and all
that.
So you had Julian's billiards,
which I do a walking tour in New York is
coming out on.
I know I've seen that before.
Fuck the three,
you have a contract city,
I'll give you a private one,
but it's like it's been,
although I've been on the today show a
Sunday today,
show the Times fucking.
It's like the best underground fucking
walk into of crime,
music and history on the lower east
side.
And we go by that whole way to palladium
was where to clash.
September 21st the cover of the
classroom learning,
calling with shot there,
Paul Seminar and smashing his base.
He had Julian's billions right there.
All the fucking pool hall hustle is.
And uh,
and,
and before the palladium it was called
the academy of Music.
Dizzy Gillespie.
Everybody played there.
And then up the street from that was
custom models.
Jim called the grammercy Jim and
everybody,
Floyd Patterson for that.
If you pull up pictures of a grammar
Nazi,
Jim,
you can see there's a picture.
And Floyd Patterson's work in the speed
bag.
And when that closed down,
cut my.
And I was just walking by one day when I
was with my mom and she goes,
your father,
because pc richards took over the space
and they put a plaque and it said,
this is where custom models,
Jim,
we train,
uh,
was it Jose Torres,
the world champions than all of these
weight classes.
And My,
my mother just goes,
oh,
your father,
box day.
I said,
what?
And there it is.
Look how they spell grammercy to g,
G,
R a.
They spelled it wrong.
Grandmas see grandma's grandma's.
See that's crazy.
They spells my name with general.
I think that it looks here.
I think it is for Patterson.
Wow.
School.
Yeah.
So we do this whole thing.
We go to a Tony Danza.
Yeah.
He took some shots and fucking I saw
some of his fights.
He could park.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
And,
and then we go by Irving Plaza where
John Belushi sounds like a lot of fun.
Dude.
It's fucking hours.
Listen,
I had these four old Israeli ladies
come,
right?
And I'm like,
and,
and all the tours meet in this area.
And they're like,
we're here for the tour.
I said,
I think you'd want the food tour over
there.
They like,
they showed me their tickets.
they like in his sixties from Israel.
They're like,
no,
we're here for the crime tour.
And they fucking did the whole three
hours.
They're like,
that was fascinating.
So in New York and Steve Lacy just texts
me.
So I'll tell you what the fuck it is.
Hold on here.
You do these on a regular basis every
week when I'm in New York or weak,
uh,
every,
Sunday.
So Steve Lacy just texts me.
Where the fuck is it when you need it?
How do you have the time to do all these
things?
Dude,
man,
uh,
you know,
I get,
I get to bed early.
Oh,
here it is.
So if you're in New York City,
August 25th,
6:30 on Fox,
it's called winner's Win New York.
Rocked Rock,
soft rock and roll history,
walking tours.
The presses underneath it.
And we go everywhere we go to fucking
the five points a.
and I've had more press.
This is actually old.
You get a kick out of doing this in love
it,
you do it every week and I'll tell you
every week you run into these
motherfuckers on the street from the old
days and I don't usually,
it's just something about it.
I'll fucking do the tour.
Like we ran into,
um,
dudes.
I'm Mick Jones from the clash or who do
we run it and nobody knew because he had
a suit on and I was like,
y'all motherfuckers know who that is.
Nobody knew it was Mick Jones.
I said,
Yo,
mic,
come on.
He's like,
oh,
well,
you know,
I was like,
listen,
I was one of the ones riding in 81 when
you played bonds,
if you go to the video clash on
Broadway,
I was there a rioting because they
oversold the club and Mayor Koch ordered
the promoter and the clash to do enough
shows.
It's called the clash on Broadway,
on Youtube.
And they ordered the class to do enough
shows and the promoter sold something
like a ticket.
It was,
I don't know,
something like 20,000 tickets for a
venue that held 2,500.
So you had close to 20,000 punk rockers
show up in Times Square.
The fire department closes the fucking
club down and there's a riot in times
square.
Now I'm a war at a time.
I'm smashing motherfucking windows.
I stopped traffic,
I'm running on cabs.
Fuck.
And then I started seeing people getting
arrested.
I'm like,
oh,
it's time to go.
But yeah,
like and then Saturday night live,
I was on that when fear played John
Belushi,
John Belushi used to come to all the
punk rock shows.
So we go to all the venues and the
famous murder spots.
And like I lived in a building with the
East village butcher,
Daniel Rakowitz.
He chopped up,
his girlfriend made soup out of her and
fed it to the homeless.
I lived in that building.
That was,
that was 700 east night.
I squatted in that building.
So it's all these fame,
the murder of a bleed.
Liba wall who on Second Avenue Deli like
and,
and famous movies.
Then we go to the smuggling tunnels of
prohibition.
A lot of shit you saw on boardwalk
empire.
So it's a pretty fascinating tour.
And I always like the first time I did
it and I'll just leave it as,
it was really funny because I had like
40 people in,
some of them were from Germany.
So I'm going down and I'm fucking,
we'd go down to avenue B and I'm like,
yeah,
that was a big fucking drugs by here.
So this huge black dude.
I know he just got out of prison.
He's like fucking six,
five key Lloyd scar across his face.
He's like,
Yo,
what's up man?
Fuck you doing man.
What's up?
I ain't seen you in a minute.
I was like,
Oh,
I do this tour,
you know,
these are all tourists.
I'm taking them around to all the drugs
spots and letting them know about the
crime.
There is like word.
So he gets up on the curb.
He's like huge dude,
you know,
prison build.
Like he say,
let me tell you all motherfuckers some
right now,
y'all better listen to this man because
none of y'all motherfuckers would have
calmed down your back in the day.
I would have fucking rob all you got to
take taking your sneakers,
everything.
And they were like,
and then he's like,
Yo,
peace my mastery around blood clot.
And they were like,
you hear these Germans go,
oh my God,
that guy was fucking crazy.
So you will see all the dude.
You can't make this shit up.
I gotta wrap this up.
I got Joseph.
Thank you.
Great job.
Thank you very,
very much.
We're going to have some fun this
weekend too.
Bye everybody.
We'll be back tomorrow with mark.
Delegate.
Cool.